come one and all thank you for joining
us today on the h3 podcast live look
who's back in the studio your girl
today's episode is sponsored by Dollar
Shave Club quip and honey I gotta say we
have been slamming all day we're a
little bit late only four minutes but I
was thinking I was like man we used to
be like an hour late and we also didn't
even prepare like we've been here since
8:00 a.m. I like I say I'm proud of all
the guys back there
we've been slamming and jam I know we've
had all kinds of weird beginnings before
on YouTube how do we stick it how did we
do yeah we've been really trying sir
YouTube's a different game man you get
it right you get one shot so Dan how'd
we do well it felt good out here I don't
hear you and the wood everything said
shits hit in the Flint okay there yeah
we're all good I will have to go back
and check it felt pretty good though
timing felt good on y'all good we will
have to all right what's today's show
we've got a slammin hot one you guys let
me tell you what's coming up in the
intern whose birthday it is today
congratulations to him has put together
a PowerPoint presentation for us on the
Drake verse push a tee drama there's
been some real ugly back-and-forth
between the two of those freestyle
battle that's reminiscent of the good
old 90s when rappers would just were
straight-up killing each other so let's
hope that it doesn't escalate there but
the fireworks are setting off and Ian is
really he's the keeper of culture and
knowledge and he's gonna come in he's
gonna tell us really what's going on
because break down the lyrics hopefully
as well what makes him the keeper of
culture well he's a young man and he's
basically he's weirdly obsessed with
Kanye and sometimes he he concerns me
he concerns me to some degree for
example yesterday he's on the freeway he
pops a flat tire he rolls over to the
side of the 101 freeway probably one of
the most dangerous places to be in the
world there's there's there's side of
the 101 and running the bolts number two
he pulls over and he's like I know I
should call triple-a to come change my
tire but I'm I have to watch this Kanye
stream because he was streaming his new
album
so he's sitting there watching this
Kanye livestream cuz he's so into it
while cars zip past him on the
one-on-one yeah so he's he's he's in
deep that would get you qualified for
the keeper of culture yeah he's the
keeper of culture like an important
detail here's to ya the livestream for
about two hours was just a open field
with horses so that that's what kept him
on the side you know are you on the mic
yeah yeah so tell me when you were on
the side of the 101 we did anything
danger did you ever feel that you were
in danger at that point it didn't really
matter because the stream was up right
there and and and as nothing happened in
the stream did you find yourself more
more frustrated and confronted with the
you know actuality that you were gonna
have to call triple-a and possibly miss
something once that started to come into
play I did get a little worried but my
battery looked good so I was okay what I
tell you is this guy qualified or won so
he's coming in he's gonna let us know
what's going on up after that we've got
Kyle the cougar champ and Skippy the
virgin we got these two great minds on
the phone together these two guys are
the founding members of our great minds
league the league of extraordinary minds
and we got him on the phone together to
see how they interact cuz I thought hey
you know Kyle he's a cougar champ he's
seen the ropes he's been there he's done
this maybe he can give Skippy some
advice yeah well yeah fireworks flew I
have to say I did not expect what
happened because they ended up actually
getting in a bit of a fight yeah Skippy
got super angry at Kyle so that was that
was really something so we're actually
recorded that this morning because I
always have all these technical
difficulties when I have calls and I
wanted to make sure when you have two
beautiful minds like this you want to
make sure that everyone every word is
hurt right it's that important so I
cannot wait to share that with you guys
and finally we've got a new segment
called Ethan go to your room where I
face the music I've said look when
you're on a podcast you say a lot of
dumb [ __ ]
that's kind of the nature of the beast
I'm sitting here with an open mic for
two hours okay so I've said a lot of
dumb [ __ ] here and a lot of the stuff
that we should I
I'm not even throw you I should correct
the record okay so Ethan go I just don't
say anything so which is I wish I had
that option not much to correct yeah
you're smart so that's coming up and not
only that we've got voice messages and
news and so much more to get to my guys
so what that being said let's get right
to flip into it now today we were
supposed to have Tommy Weis oh and Greg
Sestero on but once again
Tommy Wiseau is probably the most
challenging guest ever to book of all
time I didn't want to say anything the
first time because I was trying to keep
a professional you know but he literally
we had him booked and that the it was
the morning of or the evening of I was
like I had a bad feeling I was like I
get the feeling Tommy's not coming and
you know in that week I prepared so much
for him I was like I was knee-deep and
all this Tommy wise oh listen you can
only watch so much Tommy wise oh and I
had watched a lot of Tommy wise oh
that's me yeah so that morning I was
like Danny I got a feeling man I don't
know can you just reach out to them and
make sure they're coming so Dan reaches
out them in the morning up and they're
like oh yes sorry Tommy is really busy
he's not gonna make it so I was gonna be
polite and be like a scheduling issues
but this time it happened again I'm not
exactly this time right it kind of
happened again and this time was a
little stranger but they're I don't know
you couldn't make it in well the only
time they could make it was right when I
was coming off the plane basically but
we call it and we emailed and everything
he's got this receptionist at a
yahoo.com email that apparently says
receptionist but I have a feeling it's
just him was that your impression damn
that we were just talking about yeah
yeah we were skeptical right from the
get-go
it the the at Yahoo just seemed suspect
from the beginning I don't
so where we'll get him in here
eventually but so anyway he's really uh
he's we all considering doing it but it
was so tight with my flight that I don't
think it would have worked
no it wouldn't work yeah anyway god
bless tom thank you thank you I wish you
were here to it so we could expand on it
but hopefully soon looking guy dougie
yeah we can get them in here and get the
true real story of Tom and wise Oh
Eva how was your trip you just got back
on Tuesday mm-hmm it's weird every time
I go back I guess I get more used to the
states the longer I'm here you know
every time I go back it gets weirder and
weirder for me right Mike oh you realize
how loud everyone is oh yeah I think
everyone is yelling all the time I don't
want their Israeli stereotypes or real
like the stereotype is that they're
these bald shouting Hermes rocky you
know everyone's doing this you go there
yeah it's real it's real man I remember
the last time we were there this is such
an Israeli experience we took a taxi
I'm Tel Aviv de les parents house why
don't you tell me where you were
speaking Hebrew with him I was I was
like I need to go to this address my
parents house and it's like it's near a
famous Junction so I was like near this
Junction but I'll tell you how to get
there when we get there because no one
knows the exact address right
they don't really put ways not all do
not all the drivers it's like old school
her old school you also can't pay with
card um which is like I got used to it
here they beat their kids in Israel
their old school they don't do that
subdue sound but so anyway we get to
that Junction and then he's like he's
about to continue straight when you need
to make a left and I'm like you gotta go
left here and he he just refused he's
like no I'm going straight here this is
not what you told me
just make a left it's like we're two
minutes away and you wouldn't do it and
then we just I don't I don't even
remember any system we we had that it
was on the meter which what I didn't
understand right you're paying him we
weren't not trying to scam him he picked
this out basically on the side of the
freeway
it was a super it's busy junction we
basically got kicked out because it's
got refused to drive another five
minutes dealers house and then and then
it was like putting on the you know the
receipt like here's what I'm what I'm
gonna charge you you know when they like
close it and prints the receipt and I
was like I'm not paying you you're not
thinking me what I need to go yeah yeah
that was being Israeli you guys seen it
she's shouting in Hebrew he's shouting
in Hebrew is all this going on can you
shout at Hebrew say stood me favorite
say I'm not I'm not [ __ ] paying you
say that in Hebrew I don't I don't curse
in here I'm not paying you say that in
Hebrew and you'll always showdown at
likhaan that's good but too happy yeah
we got off at the junction and then I
had to call my dad and he came and pick
this out yeah but that's that's just one
little thing that would happen to you
that's typical yeah that's Israel but
one thing that did happen that is worth
talking about is that elos brand-new
wack book air I don't think you're gonna
correct me now that you drop $3,400 on
stopped working it it wouldn't charge
yeah I don't know why I plugged it in
left for the whole day I was like I'm
gonna come back here to be fully charged
and then it was dead I just found the
total area you know I'm sorry when you
sped a converter yeah I I don't know
what happened it was supposed to work
yeah I know and you spent $3,400 it's
gotta work it's only been like a month
yeah I gotta say that my razor laptop
that costs $1,000 less has been kicking
butt yeah cuz once I you can take it to
Israel so what there's just something in
the air there get yelled at by too many
Israelis
stops working but the razor laptop is
really slammin I got to say 2000-3000
I've been loving I set this up at my TV
in our bedroom
I plug in a wireless keyboard a mouse
and I game PC games on my TV with this
baby and it crushes I don't know what to
tell you
I well I need to go through the whack
folks tour yeah too good
I'm this is not my charger right now
still don't have a charger but actually
I think we have a whoa we have a call in
from somebody from Apple you're calling
in right now that the more they actually
wanted to talk to you about what
happened to your computer ill oh okay
oh hello yes hello hey is this someone
from Apple this is Apple yes how are you
I'm fine we've just have been having
this issue with ILA's laptop and it just
doesn't seem right that that you know
this piece would break for three four
hundred dollars oh I'm sorry that you
don't know how to use it I'm sure I can
assist you with that did you take it
anywhere did you take it somewhere
yellow yes I took it to Israel
okay Israel did any Israelis yell around
it no are you sure because this I mean
it's Israel Who am I speaking to
oh this is Ringo Ringo why does it sound
like you're in heaven what is this
angelic music I'm at the Genius Bar
oh the Genius Bar okay okay this is just
how it sounds so what do we do how do we
fix this well first of all you're gonna
have to become certified to use an Apple
charger we offer a program though would
you like to get signed up for it it's a
how do I fix it I just want to fix this
piece what you you want to fix it we
don't fix things at Apple okay all right
all right I hang up on this on this
kalam that was Apple apparently called
into the show and go well unbelievable
did they just pile it in like that
little shocking is that your personal
number yeah I just I'm dialed in you
know we're on tight
all right we've got I saw this video
this is so good
Ryan Seacrest Ryan Seacrest he seems
like such a wholesome guy right yeah
he's not well right I don't know if we
can well well here's here's the clip and
this is just so good I actually thought
he was gay I almost didn't even have a
doubt about it
but on what is the show American Idol or
what was it well sooner they show top
one of these talent shows whatever
they're all the same I don't know how
they [ __ ] up this bed he doesn't know
that they came back and he's flirting
with Katy Perry like in a really creepy
way and it just blows my mind that a
show this big could blunder like they
didn't know they were bad well just go
ahead and play it then I think we're
back I've seen I've seen people saying
you know they thought maybe it was a bit
but there's a moment when he looked
crazy I doesn't he's right and you're
like that's real he says to her he says
your mom's hot yeah and then he and then
he says you're not a mom yet do you want
to talk about it it's weird but it's so
beautiful that this was captured why
Ryan Seacrest create like bro this is
not the time or place even like if is
this a me to a moment is this a subtle
me to a moment to have the balls to
creep on her that blatantly here right
where there are locations about him to
me to stuff I think there was something
about a hairdresser I don't remember
what the allegations were but yeah you
want to talk about it I love that are
you mom let's talk about it hey hey I am
I'm gonna see you to see that again Dan
there you go
rod the mom's pretty is this the
conversations that take place off I
[Laughter]
think we're back yes that is so weird
like you know this is like I'm the
biggest production in the world makes me
feel a bit a bit better about what we're
doing here you want to talk about it
it's so awkward so so saddling me to a
moment well I have to say a very subtle
one I have to I kind of agree because I
have to say to have the balls to talk
like that - not only anyone but Katy
Perry like the biggest most famous
powerful woman in Hollywood but also of
other dudes it's hey you want to talk
about it
damn what happened his face his face
looks kind of looks like there were you
were right his there's a what do we got
stylists that has accused television
host of multiple instance of sexual
harassment abuse over seven years as she
worked for him well if you worked for
him for seven years it's almost kind of
hard to be like take those very
seriously I had I was so miserable for
seven years my off the mark you quit
right after seven [ __ ] years of being
sexually her
maybe a year maybe two years seven
that's high school and college it's hard
to do better as a stylist than ryan
seacrest though right i mean that's
that's a hard gig to walk away from it's
probably good money well I don't know
what she accused him off what do we got
here just making comments like that you
want to talk about it yeah hey look what
you do with my hair see you're not a mom
yet you want to talk about it what can I
do
can I help you become a mom see it says
right secrets groped her vagina rubbed
his erect penis against her while clad
only in his underwear and slapped her
buttocks so hard that it left a large
welt still visible hours later I'd say
after seeing that I believe it oh my god
I believe it after I saw that that was
like a really creepy weird thing you
want to talk about it your mom's hot
your mom's hot can I rub my boner on you
you want to talk about making a baby
kind of interesting but but if I'm Ryan
Seacrest
I wouldn't even like you know that it's
a hard cut back to live television
I wouldn't even [ __ ] blink if you're
gonna be creepy weirdo who would like
you know after the show yeah I wonder if
she's so like protected that he almost
doesn't even have access to her he's
like [ __ ] this is my only tonight to
make a pass on Katy Perry in between uh
in the commercials yeah also it takes a
lot of I mean I know you're Ryan
Seacrest and you're you're kind of a big
deal but come on dawg you're not you're
not Katy Perry material right no I I
don't think he has a chance with her
he's got a [ __ ] chance but maybe just
you know he can help her be a mom and
nothing more
yeah you could help me be a mom let's
talk about that a little bit later if
you want to put your dick in me and then
I'm pregnant me nice all right you've
been on this long enough but I just
thought that was real uh I thought it
was an interesting glimpse inside yeah
find the camera right
I believe it god we've been talking
about Ian a lot but Ian was actually
banned from the Kanye subreddit dan was
telling me that and I just I get worried
about that boy I feel like I'm caring
for him I feel like is in my custody and
I just I get worried about him sorry yes
you were banned from posting how the I
don't think it wasn't the subreddit
right oh yeah I was like here your mics
open go ahead no it's the main Kanye fan
site it's called Kanye to the calm Kanye
to the calm and you've been basically
thrown out of this community in yeah
they got me out of there pretty quick
why are you come in here come in here we
were goes we're gonna get into the Drake
Pusha T thing but let's let's get your
ass in here we got a lot to talk about
I'm worried about you and you're you're
it you're in too deep you're pulling
over on the side of the road to watch
Khan you're getting banned from Kanye
why were you banned from a Kanye forum
to not go too much into it I posted a
leak to an unreleased song mm-hmm and
that is not in the rules did you know it
wasn't in the rules when you posted it
yes so why did you do it to seem like I
was in the know there is their street
cred and in these forms that you're
trying to impress other people they're
in the digital streets right and it and
was there talk about you being banned
are you big contributor to this forum I
thought I was but they forgot me pretty
clearly nobody cared about your ass
disappearing interesting did you have
you made any please to get unbanned with
them I have tried yes no response well
see they banned my IP address and so I
tried to make an account under a
different IP and somehow they knew and
they banned me again well they're
serious about it now when you when you
knowingly broke the rules did you expect
that
just had enough street cred that you
could go into the radar yeah I was like
I'm I'm big dog you know what was your
user name on their forum I can't say
that oh really
I can't reveal it really I'll meet him
no no I can't I can't why not that it's
bad but it all still exists there and
all the Pug you wanna dig in like I
don't care about your post history I'm
just curious what you're you may not but
who knows I can't have these can you get
me out all right fair enough fair enough
I don't want people to know you could be
like banned from a fan sighs oh yeah I
don't even well Ian you take things too
far quite clearly yeah they went we like
fans but you're a little too near too
much of a fan let me ask how did you
feel when you when you realize you were
banned I went no I'll get back on thank
you they need me they can't ban me yeah
I'm valuable to this community right no
are you looking for like other artists
no stupid to be joining their friend
yeah no one has no one really is doing
it for me I'm not getting that
interesting
alienated now do you feel like you don't
have any place to belong now that you've
been banned no I'm just floating around
I tried read it doesn't cut it
Kanye subreddits too lightweight not far
enough what's interesting Kanye fact you
could share with us the deepest seediest
weirdest one the weirdest one uh he
spent two years in China as a toddler
live guy that's a weird one I am I'm
knocking someone won't take that away
from you definitely hit me on that one
by the way we made a stinger for Ian dan
can you leave and come back in come back
in would you please we have we had hot
dad put together all stinger claw don't
pretend close the door come back in all
right go ahead everybody now
[Music]
[Applause]
very good very nice by the way I'm
announcing anybody out there who's up
for the challenge I want to make an e in
the interne song competition so if you
have any if you want to take a stab at
it and give your submissions send them
on over to Dan dan what is it what's the
email podcast at HP productions.com do
it okay sinew product I want stingers I
want full remakes I want to hear
everything you've got and we'll go over
all the top submissions so ian has put
together basically you know what we
should take a quick break where it's
about that time so we're gonna take a
look right when we come back ian is
going to give us a presentation on Jake
verse Pusha T all the drama and all the
juice that is transpired I'm looking
forward to it
better not be boring I'll try my best
all right I'm counting on you we're
gonna need all the help we can get here
today don't go away we'll be right back
Dollar Shave Club delivers everything
you need to look feel and smell your
very best
you name it shampoo conditioner body
wash toothpaste hair gel even a wipe
that will leave your tush feeling tingly
clean which is the perfect adjective to
describe my anus tingly I'm a big fan of
their amber amber and lavender calming
body wash I got to tell you it's
masculine but it smells good people will
give you a sniff and they'll say yes it
smells flowery and lavender but it's
still masculine right and I know you
know what I mean helos she cuddles up to
me sometimes she smells me I'm like this
come on no I'm never that that lavender
that amber Mike all right dude give me
some space for chrissake crowding me
it's that good
all of dollar shapes clubs products are
made from top-shelf ingredients that
won't break your budget you'll feel the
difference plus shipping is included
with your membership and here's a great
way to try a bunch of Dollar Shave Club
products for just 5 bucks you can get
their daily essential starter set it
comes with body cleanser one wipe
Charlies their amazing tingly inducing
butt wipes
they're world-famous shave butter and
their best razors you know and even the
love it the six blade executive weighty
meaty handle them make your face tingle
you'd be tingling all over boy how about
this your anus isn't the only place
you'll be tingling
good pitch for Dollar Shave Club
keep the blades coming for a few bucks
more a month and add in shampoo
toothpaste or anything else you need for
the bathroom check it all out at
dollarshaveclub.com
slash h3 that's dollarshaveclub.com
slash h3 thank you guys so much for
supporting our sponsor thank you Dollar
Shave Club let's get right back into it
shall we
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys for sticking around we're
back first of all before we get into
this in it is your birthday and how old
are you today
24 well yes you know we're very we are
worried about you you have some strange
habits we love you you we appreciate you
you do good work and we want us to show
a gesture and take care of you can you
look under your seat please
I have repeatedly said that I am Oprah
and as an Oprah does you know that I
always come bearing gifts
I thought you were drinking me nope no
Joe read it okay read it read what's on
the front it says happy birthday in the
intern from the entire age three gang
open it up he's opening the envelope
I've always wanted to go ahead come on
describe what's okay happy birthday from
the same thing actually alright really
drill it in only use on salmon burritos
what is it a 50 dollar Sharky's car 50
dollar shark is gift card you
you think that I'm gonna let that go
you're dead wrong I swear to God if I
I'm in cooked in with Sharky's and I'm
gonna check that gift card on a daily
basis nice thing you bought anything
that's a member he does well no I
I just finished using the other one and
I was like I'm free oh I'm out you have
to use all three I got a couple shared
it a little bit 50 bucks
well thank you I should have got a
thousand just never-ending Simon forever
happy birthday thank you enjoy that
enjoy that okay you have put together a
presentation for us in yeah take us away
all right so as most of you know push it
T verse Drake yep Clash of the Titans
here is push it to you Titan he's a
Titan in in my eyes okay okay but he is
then here's a Titan yeah okay alright so
to understand this conflict we must go
back okay mm - wow this has been brewing
a while now Jesus Christ hold on hold
you this was comprehensive this is this
is possibly more than I bargained for
here a simpler time the rapper Birdman
aka baby aka the number one stunner
releases his debut album
it features Pusha T on the Pharrell
produced track what happened to that boy
it is a jam I'd say so it's a great song
but these happy times are not here to
stay
you wrote it's a jam I wrote it said you
don't like to assign it to Jane okay
because you're like it's a jam I'd say
so it's a really good song what the
PowerPoint says it's a jam so I agree
with make sure that you wrote that cuz
it was in 2006 disaster strikes right
rap superstar and Birdman protege little
Wayne is photographed for the cover of
vibe magazine wearing Bape clothing
really is that a problem
can you imagine the nerve of this man
well what's the issue well the issue is
next slide slide then push it t is known
for often wearing babe clothing
alongside Pharrell he believes that mr.
Wayne is stealing his style
Rancic cold give me a freakin break it's
tough out here there he is there he is
upset that little wheezy is wearing bait
yes I bet you I know who's not upset
he's wearing babe who babe oh definitely
not
so then push it t responds on the sister
Reader's Digest version of this I mean
if you wanna sip through it there's just
not too much a couple slides thirty
fourteen and you know okay so anyways
there's some beef pusher attacks am
still in my style
Lil Wayne says who the [ __ ] is Pharrell
do you really respect him he wore babe
and y'all thought he was weird I wore it
and you thought it was hot so he's
calling him out
Pusha T and Lil Wayne are having some
struggle okay he's looking sad here oh I
was like very careful laser pointer this
thing is actually illegal to possess
it's so powerful there are casualties in
these beefs Wow would have expected it
was nice first one down so things seem
to quiet down for a bit you know
everyone seemed to be like it's cool do
you still have vision are you okay I'm
seeing I'm not gonna lie I'm seeing I'm
seeing a green dot yeah I'm seeing a dot
but go ahead don't don't let me
interrupt you mhm
okay push the t drops Exodus 23:1 the
diss track that shakes things up he
attacks lil wayne birdman he's upset
things are looking dicey not what caused
this over the babe situation oh I
thought it cooled down it cooled down
for a bit and then he came back a little
late I have to say he so let me get this
straight push it too
was upset that they were wearing babe
yeah I have to say point against your
boy pushup because that's some petty ass
[ __ ] it is but then little Wayne in that
interview says you know who is he I
don't give a [ __ ] about him right now
he's he's not me and that and that did
make it worse but I mean okay so push it
to you touch the air that's his
catchphrase can you get a sample of that
do we have if I can track down that I'm
sure you can get a couple X okay so
Birdman and Lil Wayne are on Young Money
Entertainment and Cash Money Records
mm-hmm the next slide down real quick
Drake is signed to both Young Money and
cash money oh those are his guys didn't
take very long for Lil Wayne to respond
in the next one it's a very small text
there you go
[ __ ] Pusha T and anybody that loved them
Lil Wayne is not happy Lil Wayne has a
lot of weight in his words right like
how do people respond to this tweet this
is from 2012 we are really going way
back yeah mu I have to say I even
underestimated you knowing that you're
the keeper of culture and knowledge
you've going back to 2012 on my ass
impressed there's a lot there's a lot to
him did you have to do Rio just since
last night
yes did he put this together in like an
hour off the top of that well actually I
kinda have slideshows just for me I
don't get any scenario so Lil Wayne and
Drake are really close Lil Wayne's
pissed off
Drake is mad he wants to defend his
mentor who is Lil Wayne you could skip
it you say no it's just some just some
information some stuff I'm just as
famous as my mentor but that's still the
boss don't get what is what is that we
don't need to read all this this is
Drake kind of sending the little shots
and kind of his 2012 song
I'm as famous as my mentor he's talking
about Lil Wayne that's still the boss
get hype on tracks and jump in front of
the bullet you weren't meant for so he's
kind of going push it t leave Lil Wayne
alone
you don't want to mess with me right
right right so then things cool off
until 2015 fast forward 2014 jumping up
Meek Mill I won't use the laser pointer
I almost don't know I found it I stole
it did you find it on the Kanye fan site
no I can't go back there go back now let
me tell anyone ask when you go to the
website is it just straight blocked out
or you can't or doesn't allow you to log
in can you view other people can't view
it yeah they let you give a taste
have you tried a VPN yes and they found
out yeah is [ __ ] if I could make like
a plea will you guys let me back now are
you kidding or is it really that
important to you well I mean it's like
album time there's a lot of discussion I
can't get in on but you can read it but
you can't participate is that really a
big deal for you I've got the insights
I've got right stuff to say I've got
power points right how many and I want
to know specifically how many hours a
week do you spend on that website before
you were banned I don't know if I want
to think about that information it's
it's a lot it's a lot I gotta say you're
interesting you're an enigma you know I
don't know I mean I'm mesmerized by that
guy so I might know a lot about him but
anyways I want to know what your form
name something interesting is it
something that would make me a lot no
it's just some random so yeah just
random okay would you tell me if it was
okay all right let's go
okay so Meek Mill comes in you guys may
have heard of this back in the day Meek
Mill tweets this out stop comparing
Drake to me he don't write his own raps
ouch that's why he ain't tweet my album
because we found out Wow big shots fired
he exposes Drake says he uses ghost
writers can I point something out yeah I
find interesting more retweets than
likes I find that to be bizarre that was
also the case with a little Wayne tweet
there was more retweets how do you
explain that that to me says BOTS if I'm
being honest because who-who would
retweet this and not like it I find that
very
bizarre more people would like then not
retweet then retweet am I wrong I I
think so unless there's people who are
trying to like stir the pot as well I'm
just gonna so maybe they're like maybe
they're supporters of Drake and they're
like I want everyone to see this idiot
yeah I don't like ya interesting I want
to make sure controversial therefore
more retweets could possibly be
justified mm-hmm interesting okay so
Meek Mill accuses Drake offending Ghost
Rider by the name of Quinton Miller on
this 2015 track reco and now can you
tell me the backstory on ghost writing
that's frowned upon in the hip-hop world
yeah why is that which is strange
because most most musicians use writers
I'm sure but for some reason hip-hop
kind of has this thing where that is
very very frowned upon right but they
all still do it you think that a lot of
I feel like they all do well I think I
don't know I've heard stories of like
you go into Dre's office so you go to
Kendrick or some big boy calls you in
and they make you cut right there lyrics
in front of you on the spot so they know
that it wasn't ghost written by somebody
I think part of it if I'm understand it
correct me if I'm wrong as the keeper of
quoting your knowledge is that it's
poetry it's personal it's your own
expressive art and so it is a little
elitist I have to say when you're making
music but I suppose that's where it
comes from right yeah and also in a
world where they're all like I'm better
than you you can't really say oh I'm
better than you when other people are
making it for you right maybe that's
something do with it that's the thing no
one's really going like who are the top
five pop artists but it's always the
debate of who's the best rappers there
so yeah they like that person
personality just shining through so it's
very frowned upon yeah
next so through a whirlwind of memes and
the release of the grammy-nominated diss
track back to back meek was defeated by
the almighty Drake he was you just
crowned him Victor yeah everyone kind of
did whirlwind of memes and releases so I
do have more detail I'm Michael I think
Drake kind of won that beef because of
the memes he had the power of me
it's like High Noon so the people won
that battle firm I think are you
participating in that battle no I was a
spy standard you are a bystander yes
were you interested at the time vaguely
yeah I was interest you weren't on
forums or anything like that I was
around okay but I was Kanye's not evil
Kanye's yes he's in this new one so I'm
very sure but no and then the song was
good the diss song he released against
Meek Mill was very good
however Pandora's box had been opened
regarding the ghost riding allegations
pusha t did not forget sure
so what yeah you think it's already been
stained on his name cut to 2016 right
Pusha T releases the song hgtv freestyle
with the following lyrics it's too far
gone when the real estate real and next
with each of these lines did the slide
Drake has a project called so far gone
Wow I walk amongst the clouds so your
ceilings ain't real that they think
that's reference to Drake's interesting
album nothing was the same these blank
and words Call of Duty cuz their
killings ain't real with the
questionable pen so the feeling a real
so people think he's pretty obviously
calling out what's your opinion when you
sing Kanye songs do you say that and
word when you're at you're by yourself
at home
no definitely not what do you what how
do you not skip it or do you say and how
do you approach this when you're singing
by yourself in the shower what do you
say I take a moment to pause and reflect
seriously what do you do it's such a
dicey thing I mean you're in the shower
by yourself there's not even anybody
home you're singing the lyrics to a
Kanye song that you love you know every
word what do you do when the ad word
comes up see that's the thing is because
everyone says it that you say everyone
say it because it's like you get it you
have a cadence let it be known I agree
by the way you're singing you're by
yourself what can you do you get in
passion I'm just curious I'm glad thank
you for being on to you not me no no no
never know all right
[Laughter]
next slide damn please let's get let's
just drop the crying Drake so two weeks
later
Drake replies on his song two birds one
stone questioning the legitimacy of
Pusha T's drug-dealing past
Pusha T is always rapping about how he
sells cocaine okay that's his thing
Drake is yeah he's not happy about the
disses thrown his way the accusations
yeah he's he's getting kind of annoyed
of everyone saying he writes are we
milking this is this going to long I'm
actually interested I'm intrigued you
guys everybody stopped watching by now
I'm actually in deep play the stinger
play the sting
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you
Drake replies really it's you with the
drug stories that's got a stop though
you made a couple of chops now you think
your chapo mmm you ask me though you
ain't lining the trunk with kilos you
bagging weed watching Pacino with all
your words and words like this is what
we need to be on but you never went live
you're a middle man in this you're not
one of those guys Wow so he's saying all
of this does not hard yeah everything
you rap about is is fake sure he also
attacks Kid Cudi on the song who also
brought up his ghost writing allegations
on Twitter okay so so Drake is attacking
Pusha T for being affiliated with Kid
Cudi who's been alleged to have to have
ghost riders as well no Kid Cudi called
out Drake for having ghost riders Oh
everybody's piling on Trey yeah and
Pusha T and Kid Cudi are close they're
interesting so Drake kind of goes you
were the man on the moon now you're
going through your phases you stays and
and perked up so when reality sets in
you don't have to face it look what
happens soon as you talk to me crazy
is you crazy that's it that's a strong
those are those are pretty strong words
to accuse a man of being a drug addict
and that's right before that with the
next slide Dan Cudi had recently checked
into a rehabilitation clinic for
substance abuse and suicidal tendencies
pretty mean spirited now was his words
before after the check in I think it was
after okay so that's so that's putting
salt in the wound yeah Cuddy is in a
rehab at the time and he tweeted this at
Drake say it to my face [ __ ] you think
it's a game I want to see you say it to
my face I'll be out soon
whoa that's I didn't real okay this is
interesting now this is actually heating
up quite a bit it goes eating slides in
let me ask you what kind of guy do you
think Drake is do you think that he's
misunderstood because this is what this
is mean and I see Cuddy is taking it
really very personal well that was the
thing at which I wanted to include this
because so many people are going
is getting attacked too hard right now
and I'm like he had it coming kind of if
you go back a little he called out kid
cudi who couldn't respond he was in a
rehab clinic at foreign or suicidal
tendencies about things you know and
earnest understanding at that point yeah
and in his lines he's like you talked to
me crazy are you crazy right and and
people kind of cold on my first reaction
to the Pusha T this was that while maybe
he went too hard ya know maybe was one
of my reactions but this is the whole
context is fascinating yes proceed yeah
so after this Pusha T drops a bombshell
Daytona the 7 track coke rap homerun
album of the Year contender well was it
a cat well we know that the year is over
so album of the year is you know this
came out last week we did there was a
quiet period yes yes every since the
infamous picture so this just happened
yes album of the Year contender I think
so yes in contention with Kanye's yeah
yeah I think who's edging out right now
I mean I haven't heard Kanye's album
enough okay look at continue so on this
this is what really got it kicked off
there's a track on there called infrared
where Pusha T says it was written like
nas but it came from Quinton his
infamous ghost writer Quinton Miller do
we know who Quentin Miller is yeah he's
a rapper from Toronto and he wrecks
hometown yeah and he helped write a
couple of Drake's
songs from his 2015 album and then after
all this came out he kind of disappeared
Drake dumped him real quick
after this you think Drake dumped him
mm-hmm but you but allegedly he has more
ghostwriter swooping in and helping him
out yeah I think people kind of think
that in this case
well the accusation that is from Quentin
Dennis is black as blamele false well
it's just that he's bringing back
because Quentin's the only he's the most
known name so it's just saying you had a
ghostwriter yeah got it
yeah exactly so this was no more
subliminal shots this was a blatant
swing at the champagne poppy six God
himself
right Trey push I also used the try
to further attack Birdman and Lil Wayne
he calls them out by name in this song
who Drake is you know very close with
sure so the game was afoot the game was
afoot and we're getting close we're
almost all caught up this is exciting
stuff you guys are the numbers still
going up okay yeah we're almost lost no
longer yours is everyone invaded is
everybody in bated breath go ahead in
less than 24 hours after this song comes
out Drake fires back on the song Duffy
freestyle what's the significance of
dubby dubby is it means ghost and I
think like patois
I think what's patois it's a ghost it's
like a slang term for a slang term for
ghost so what is the significance he's
saying he's a noob like saying I'm
making you into a ghost okay you're good
okay interesting yeah interesting so he
releases this he attacks bush at E he
wrote lobs projectiles
he loves projectile yeah he says so if
you rebuke me for working with someone
else on a couple of verses what do you
really think of the blank that's making
your beats I've done N word yeah I've
done things for him I thought he never
would need father had to stretch his
hands out and get it for me I pop stop
for 30 hours then let him repeat so he's
saying he wrote for Kanye which he did
he wrote lyrics for coming West so there
was a tweet there a crow for Kanye yeah
interest and Kanye's push to tease boss
so he's essentially go it's the
difference between writing for someone
but in ghost writing goes right well
that's the thing is Kanye clearly
acknowledged he tweeted saying I want to
thank my brother Drizzy for helping me
on 30 hours and father stretch my hands
those are the songs we're ghost writing
is you don't tell anyone because you
take the credit yeah
so in the rap world is it okay if you
acknowledge people it's [ __ ] up when
you don't acknowledge and you act as if
it's your own work yeah I mean the
distinction even if you have writers
though people
still kind of looked down on that a
little bit so just did someone like
Kanye get B for a tweet like this no
because because he's like a producer as
well he produces a lot and he's kind of
the same as dr. Dre Dr Dre has a lot of
writers as well okay but he he does a
lot of production sure so people kind of
forgive it he's a jack-of-all-trades
yeah so when you do that they're kind of
okay well he's got a lot on his hands
yeah interesting so so that happens
though this is a little more aspect of
the drama that Kanye who's on the other
side of Drake now was once thinking
trick for his input mm-hm and Drake is
using that against Pusha T yeah because
Drake also in this song mentions that he
just was in Wyoming like a few weeks ago
writing for Kanye interest for his new
album which came out today Wow
so he's kind of pissed off because he's
like I keep helping you guys and your
your guys are just attacking me all the
time so he's getting kind of fed I can
tell it's boiling up this is not this is
not jokes this is not like them just
playing around this seems to be real
beef that these guys actually really
hate each other if I had to guess yeah
yeah so it's pretty much and then with
the next slide of some other lyrics leo
you know it's gonna be a cruel summer
for you I told Wayne and Birdman I'll
I'm not done him for you
can I ask you you have in parentheses
Wayne and Birdman you've substituted out
and noted it properly
yeah look seeing that correctly to bring
it back to because I was mentioning them
earlier because he kind of he says he's
alluding to them but you want to be
clear so yeah you've done us the favor
of putting it in and properly annotating
I just wanted know it to that yeah I
hope I'll get good marks at the end of
all these very things we got an invoice
coming to you considering we just sold
another 20 for you so he sends them an
invoice for promotional assistance and
career reviving 100 now e 100,000 is
that a good deal kind of yeah it's not a
bad deal yeah I think so
and there's some other lines he calls
out his drug dealing again and go ahead
read yeah I'm intrigued don't don't
let's hear it he says your brother said
it was your cousin
him than you so you don't rap what you
did you just rapped what you knew got it
Pusha T's brother was he's saying he was
more involved in the business and he was
watching God yeah and he's yeah he just
keeps saying you might have sold two
college kids for Nike and Mercedes but
you act like you sold drugs for Escobar
and the a that's pretty brutal yeah so
that's a good line
yeah that's a good line it's a it's a
good song so basically what's happened
is these guys were kind of flirting with
each other but suddenly you know and
Pusha T's recent album he took a more
overt shot and as you say the game was
afoot and that set Drake off and now the
gloves are off and Jake is Drake is
saying you know what [ __ ] this guy I'm
dedicating a song just to him yeah
they've been going back and forth for
like six years now so this is it yeah so
on the next one is it a coincidence that
both of them are dropping albums no I
don't think so you think that there's
some acknowledgment of each other and
like hey this is good publicity for us
yeah they already know it's worth coming
his album comes out this month okay but
they both putting albums out this month
do you find that that's not going sit
out do you think that they talked on the
phone behind the scenes I don't think so
some people think that I don't think
it's as explicit at that but I think
they're kind of like okay this is gonna
help me a little bit this isn't a bad
but the thing is when I heard Pusha T's
that to me well that's coming up but
what that felt to me was like these guys
are not friends they hate each other
yeah I think maybe Drake came into it
with okay this will be a good little
boost like the last one he got was being
more playful yeah let's just he's like
I'm gonna kill you yeah
the last diss track he got nominated for
Grammy for so I think he was like okay
this will just be some summer pearl
that's continued so things are quiet for
four days people think it's a rap and
Drake is one again that is until but I
gotta say Drake spent 24 hours that's
not a long time to build a craft a song
yeah I have it ready to go well people
think the review copies went out like
five or six days or
so people think Drake had a copy he was
ready to go with it yeah oh wow cuz he
heard the diss song and everyone's going
oh he released a diss in 24 hours that's
but he knew he had it because he's so
now push the t took four days to prepare
his which is actually impressive yeah
Drake doesn't really get credit for
doing it in 24 hours well I mean he's he
probably was still around like four or
five days four or five days I think it
was about the same time okay so he drops
this song the story of a deed on this
now we're up now we are fully up to date
yeah and this is a picture that he dug
up of Drake when he was younger in black
in blackface and their significance to
the clothing as well
yeah he's wearing kind of this yeah it's
it's a it's from a clothing brand that's
supposed to be kind of like an artistic
depiction but just Blake blatantly
seemed like this it does look very
offensive let me say this before we get
deep into the story of ID doll when
things really heat up let's throw it to
a quick commercial break and we'll be
right back
stay tuned y'all you know the stories
about Buddha are told wrong the truth is
he was enlightened once he used the quip
electric toothbrush and only until then
that's right this isn't toothbrush that
Buddha was reincarnated with and he took
up to heaven it's that great let me tell
you I'm obsessed with oral hygiene and I
hate shopping for toothbrush Goods it's
too firm it's too soft it's all wrong
you get an electric toothbrush it's good
it costs $200 and it's got a huge
battery pack that fits in your garage
you have to charge it in your garage not
this this is a clip electric toothbrush
it's incredible if you push the button
it vibrates brush brush brush it goes
for how long two minutes two minutes
after one minute it pulsates and reminds
you hate idiot brush the bottom that
part needs to be clean too so you get a
perfect clean brush just like your
doctor doctor recommends or your mother
there's a little voice inside here it's
your mom and your dentist it says hey
switch it up and let you know when
you're done it's bristles are soft and
perfect
it gives me a perfect clean every time I
love this toothbrush I can't endorse it
enough the best part about this truth
brush is that it just starts at 25 bucks
go to get quipped calm slash h3 right
freaking now when you get your first
refill pack which is this top part here
it just pops off and every couple months
you just put a new one on Bob's your
uncle you get that first refill pack
free with a quip electric toothbrush
listen it's a game changer it's really
one of those perfect little inventions
that's so brilliant I'm saying just give
it a shot you're gonna love this thing
that's your first refill pack free at
get quick calm slash h3 spelled g ET q
UI p.com slash h3 don't take it from me
give it a shot ela tell me about quick
brush wants transcend into the afterlife
and enlightenment you're gonna die
essentially I'm that's a bad way to
phrase it you're not gonna you're gonna
think you die how about that you get
quit thank you for sponsoring us god
bless america
i'm
close the door hey we're back I had to
pee I had to run okay real quick we have
a just a important update that happened
during the break there I received an
email from a moderator of the Kanye fan
site who is offering to unban in
controlling I don't know but some of it
some proof uh well he no he didn't offer
any proof but there's no what you are
hoping for yeah okay let me ask this
would you know his username if he said
it do you know them what all the
moderators username no I don't think
okay
I mean well if you're still listening
moderator I saw your email email again
with some proofing yeah let's get going
but wouldn't that be a wonderful
birthday gift here I'll be great all
right where were we the story of a
d-don't so we've got Drake and black
face to explain explain the significance
how he's a black man so what so I mean
what's going on here yeah I think
there's maybe more nuance to it but it's
very kind of people are having very
visceral reaction obviously it's like
blackface they're really ever he does
you there he said that it's from a photo
shoot
there was about yeah that right like I
personally can't see any other reason
why Drake a person who's half black with
done blackface other than as some you
know social yeah and he does I have the
his explanation about diversity yeah
let's blast through this so he releases
the story of a deed on he attacks
Drake's father his mother Drake's best
friend for having the disease MS a stuff
that's not really something to criticize
yeah you MS having son of a gun yeah the
way he says it you have lines
yeah his producer his name is 40 and
he's like he's hunched over like he's 80
tick tick tick
that man is sick sick sick and then he
kind of says he's done he's dying right
so brood on the tripe yeah
[Music]
he also reveals that Drake has a secret
child with porn stars Sophie Brousseau
and really yeah and kind of says that
Drake is a deadbeat dad hmm
and someone dug up a tweet of hers where
she said that she said you know [ __ ]
Drake he's a deadbeat dad about his
about the baby daddy yeah saying that
yeah Drake isn't really involved well so
and that was like really moving shakin
and that's like the significance of the
song title a deed on Drake was supposed
to release a line with adidas called a
deed on that's the rumor mm named after
his son and he was going to kind of
reveal his son to the world about his
son I find that a strange play and I
guess that's what he's happening into
that his estranged son is being used as
a marketing ploy and Khan in conjunction
with Adidas his son's name is Adonis
yeah and Pusha T's is basically saying
that Drake's
upcoming line a deed on is kind of
playfully named after his son and Pusha
T's like you should give your son a
better treatment than using him as like
a marketing tool sure and who knows if
that's true if he was going to do that
but it's brutal either way to say
because it's kind of ruined his Adidas
brand fair so when when addy Dawn comes
out everyone's gonna associate it with
you know right okay anyways and that
brings us to now Drake brought out the
iPhone knows app to try and explain
himself in the attention behind the
blackface photos yeah and so he said I
know everyone's enjoying this you go you
go ahead and read it I know everyone is
enjoying the circus but I want to
clarify this image in question this was
not from a clothing brand shoe or my
music career this picture is from 2007 a
time in my life where I was an actor and
I was working on a project that was
about young black actors struggling to
get roles being stereotyped and typecast
the photos got it I got it okay but I
find that I find that a little bit
questionable to attack a black man for
going in blackface when he did it as
part of a shoot to bring aware
to to the issue of black people having
troubles getting jobs seems a little bit
underhanded I mean that's what he says
that's what it says but I can't imagine
why why else would he do what Locke
faced as a bad guy but it is a great
little dish I mean if he's looking to
destroy the guy so is that is that uh
yeah that's it wraps it up yeah so who's
winning right now and you're in your
push it to you should eat the last is
the last one really put it over the top
once anyone opens the iPhone Notes app
it's you lost already
yeah already explaining in the iPhones
note and no one's ever used that to
explain something good right so
basically that alone has just qualified
Drake from this round yeah and push it T
tweeted last night actually saying that
he hears Drake is offering a hundred
grand for anyone who has dirt on Pusha T
that's pretty desperate a and push the
t's like you're not gonna find skeletons
that aren't their interests though and
so do you think that Drake is gonna fire
back are you anticipating it I think you
will but he's kind of running out of
time I guess okay all right thanks so
well with that being said Ian thank you
so much for sharing your knowledge and I
thank you for coming out of birthday
thank you I can't believe you put this
together so fast yeah I like I said this
boy he ain't right but we love you here
regardless of that okay yeah exactly
all right whoo well I have to say it was
long it went on a very long time a lot
of details I was intrigued
I learned yeah I did feel like I was
finally learning cuz I've seen it
everywhere lately and I didn't know
write anything about it right well now
we all know many people like follow the
details right now we all know TV's worst
makeover disaster
this clip is great we're gonna watch
this clip and then we'll jump into the
Skippy AK I'll call you guys could
probably tell we're trying to produce
this thing a little better right
I don't know if it's working exactly but
we've got clips we've got segments we're
trying to be more organized and less
loose you know I don't I don't know how
it's going but we're trying I think
there's probably a happy medium between
like being like super [ __ ] prepared
mm-hm and being more loose that we'll
figure out yeah but our intention is to
you know we want to elevate the show
we're trying stuff out trying to spice
it up we're trying to spice it up here I
hope you guys are enjoying it you know
you ready for this cringe so we've got
here the TV
let's get good I gotta set this up this
will form on some reality shows yeah all
these make it's like a Home Makeover huh
that's what it is this [ __ ] is so funny
like I feel like almost everybody's
always like uh it's okay right when you
see they like go into a tiny room and
they like repaint it and they move the
furniture and they turn a fireplace into
a wall and they're like what do you
think it's like you can tell they're
like I love it
that's like it's okay in this case this
is truly truly a disaster that this
woman who collects antiques and well
let's just go ahead and wash it then
roll it no yes when they seconds after
finishing in Linda's room disaster
struck the added weight of all those
books proved too much for the
freestanding shelves
[Music]
I don't know Andy I think we just have
to put our hands upon this one I think
you better go sit down or better tidy
this up the combination of two days hard
riding
I'm the shock of what a gentleman yeah
can you get a screen grab of when the
shelves were hanging from the ceiling
like the I have to say that was one of
the most precarious things I've ever
seen in my life
bring it back give me the just go back
to where they were hanging from the roof
there you go
what are these 90 little strings yeah
also what kind of room is this where you
just have a shelf hanging in the middle
of the room like how is no one gonna
bump into it and it's just free swinging
with the antiques you know I have to say
that's one of the dumbest things I've
ever really not that's a tiny room the
doors right there I mean what the hell
were you guys thinking yeah a shelf is
supposed to be against the wall you
optimized this space a free a free
swinging shelf with antiques on it I
love that they said it broke within
minutes - it's not like it even today
they're like you know what the antiques
aren't enough let's put all of our books
on here as well I think the books done
it yeah it's a wonderful makeover it's
really almost yeah it's almost wonder
they should they should have a show I
would watch the [ __ ] out of this called
the ultimate home makeover and what they
do is they come in and they [ __ ] your
house up Oh what was that showed that
there was well that one was real it was
a show about how it's kind of like that
but they don't mean it to be but they do
like crazy room makeovers like the
Caymans
his house and converted it into like a
chuck-e-cheese kind of thing or like a
spaceship room and it's just so [ __ ]
I'll just ruin your house yeah they base
but like in my world you come and you
just put holes in the wall and you like
you upholster all the furniture like hot
pink you know what I mean put the sink
so the water shoots out on the floor
when you turn it on and just get the
reaction like it's beautiful we part our
souls into this I hope you love it it's
very I mean this would this is pretty
much what everybody that show old
ultimate room makeovers that feel
confident these guys are you even
qualified like look at this guy in the
red sweater acting like he's actually
measuring and doing something are you
just some dude off the street do you
have a license or qualifications of any
kind a couple strings couple buh
two-by-fours forget about it I told you
guys about when I worked on a home
improvement reality show like a decade
ago yeah oh yeah yeah I was just a PA
and at least in my I don't know if this
show was like this but in my experience
they would shoot the contractor like you
know the guy in the red sweater
literally just doing what he's doing
like pretending like he's hooking
something up and then as soon as the
cameras stopped they just make the PAS
do all the work so the PAS who don't
know anything about building did they
make do that yeah oh [ __ ] they would
like having me laying concrete and like
leveling they explain to you how to do
it over they give me like a brief little
like yeah you got it
Wow never actually care about did you
ever hold anyone's house up
I didn't one I remember there was an
incident where another PA dragged this
it was like an appliance like a what do
you call a dishwasher thing just dragged
it across a wooden floor and just
annihilate oh yeah he didn't come back
did they ever fix the floor yeah they
the production had to pay for it yeah
they're like your fire we expect more of
our unpaid interns than that
all right up next we've got the main
dish fireworks we said to ourselves hey
we've got
brilliant idea let's get the great minds
together we've got Skippy the Virgin and
we've got Kyle the grandma [ __ ]
they're almost there almost like the TLC
boys they are we posted today a new
video about a do to us sex with his car
or even well that's you know I'm not
giving enough credit he's in an intimate
relationship he loves the car mm-hmm
it's not just about sex me it's about so
much more
sorry to him if I offended him I want I
really hope he reaches out one of my
favorite things is we talk about these
TLC videos and then and then add it up
you know out of the woods comes these
wonderful characters so Skippy was on
TLC yes I was the virgin and Carl yeah
so it's almost like the the learned the
the learn ed boys I'm trying to think of
a good name for them for the for the
gang we've got here the great minds of
TLC so we said to ourselves we have
these great larger-than-life
personalities Kyle who's had sex with so
many grandmas who's literally broken
vaginas in his time we talked to him
last night trying to set this up he says
hey guys I just got done [ __ ] a 79
year old he sent us a picture of them
together Skippy who did who tapes his
dates do we have footage of that Dan ooh
we do I don't think I have it cued up
though Skippy recently he got he does
this thing where he goes on dates any
films the whole thing and let me tell
you folks that is not I do have it it is
not easy city you have some like a
supercut of it yeah it's just so Skippy
the Virgin who's a devout Mormon he
defines himself by his virginity yet
he's waiting for marriage good and I
have to say Skippy you're not getting
any closer with videos like this let's
watch this is my date her name is Deanna
we are going to a comedy show it's
laughs but they're all getting skimpy
rape whistle no sex for you bracelets
kidney stickers you don't what so what's
the wildest thing you would do for a
contact mark would you kiss a guy for a
Klondike court we're getting can you
pause it
I mean Skippy you're basically you're
you're approaching her for prostitution
in exchange it for all things a Klondike
bar it's a you know it's one thing to
get paid $1,000 to suck a guy's dick
it's a whole nother thing to do for a
Klondike bar it seems like they're
having fun though
you think so go back look at her face
well we everything we saw up to this
point was before the date like on the
way to the date right here is where
we're at the attitude changes a little
bit
dan can you go back 10 seconds and
everyone watch her face has he
propositioned her for a Klondike bar
right here what's what's the wildest
thing you would do for a contact mark
would you kiss a guy for a Klondike bar
we're getting this woman a Klondike bar
okay progressed when was the last how
long since your last relationship over a
year ago how long is the longest is
really to eat leave you have like a two
to five year relationship in yet let's
ooh I think I've had technically three
girlfriends and I've made out with I
want to say yeah Wow no girls ever
grabbed his dick 49 make outs you never
touched at it I guess that's not sex
yeah okay go ahead sorry sorry to pause
we've thought about like people in
relationships kissed the same person
over and over again it's like one person
2,000 times as opposed to
yeah or 49 people you know what people
asked me was like hey Skippy are you
still a virgin the title of the video oh
yeah big secret I'm yeah we didn't have
sex you were there you were you were
conscious for the whole I shouldn't
normally have to ask this but can you
let people know I didn't roofie you once
on a scale of one to ten how do you
think the date went good possibility I
think we should okay hey nothing needs
to be more said about this legend she
was into it at first it was a long
[ __ ] night it was daytime yeah I did
something when they came back she was
just like take me yeah I mean alright
let's let's roll it we've got--we've so
we got them together these two great
minds this morning and I says Kyle
you've got the knowledge you've got the
experience and the and the [ __ ] the
old ladies is kind of a easy one in - so
can you talk to Skippy I want to get
this guy some play mm-hmm
so without further ado let me tell you
fireworks
it started one way and it ended a whole
nother way with them it was Skippy
actually yelling at Kyle unbelievable
what a treat
what that being said let's let's enjoy
the show I am on the phone with Skippy
the Virgin and Kyle the cougar champ
here I thought that you know with the
knowledge that Kyle the cougar champ has
he could really share and improve on
Skippy's life but before I get into that
whole thing I kind of just want to check
in with everybody Skippy are you there
yeah hey hey Skippy how are you you guys
you know what you guys have made my life
much more enjoyable and entertaining I
deliver pizzas and I get like I've had
experiences where I've shown up and
they're like wait you're Skippy and I'm
like yeah and they're like can I get a
photo and
like I said before or after the photo
right now are you getting more - awesome
are you getting more tips as a result of
being associated with us yes we know
that you get the money if I'm never
gonna move out
I'll have dant contact you about
collecting our commission on that but we
can deal with that Skippy have you seen
our new video we covered one of your
contemporaries a TLC documentary about a
young man that has sex with a car did
you catch that
no I avoid that but yeah is putting your
dick let me ask you this I can you have
sex with the cars that's something that
your religion would allow cuz I know
you're waiting for marriage but are you
allowed for your dick and a tailpipe
before marriage I think you could do
that as long as it's consensual and but
if in a month what am I talking about
only consensual people would be yeah yes
only object sir can you do the boat so
your bishops okay with that yeah I any
well you know I would still tell them
that oh yeah yeah Skippy if you can you
get up and before we check in with your
next can you check with your bishop and
get his take if you are allowed to put
your dick in the tailpipe I'd like to
follow up on that as possible I would
gently be super embarrassed to ask him
that so from that won't happen but that
that's something that they we've Skippy
if you buy it if you put your dick in a
car's tailpipe would you tell your
bishop yeah of course I would course I
would think that means I have mental
problems and I need psychological help
so yeah sure or of course of course
okay Kyle for help is what it is Kyle
the Cougar chimp nice to have you here
god bless you how have you been doing
telling you update me yeah just wow this
what you guys are saying I'm Les Miles
being on the 76 your grandma singer
picture that um when I was talking on
your producers
yeah I saw a picture of her she's I saw
her and my reaction was like damn she's
really old Kyle like that's impressive
he's recently got a came 70 surgery
later on this month kyle is the cane
turn you on more or less
like how do you physic ain't enhance the
sexual experience mm-hmm hot I'm
wondering like okay if he's getting
recognized and whatnot why isn't anyone
[ __ ] them at the door okay yeah sure
so well yeah okay let's let's go ahead
and get right into it here we've got
questions for all of our ourselves Kyle
let's start there Skippy you don't have
sex because you are waiting for marriage
is that correct
exactly exactly it's not that I can't
it's that I want to wait until I get
married now Kyle yeah it's a religious
thing y-yeah but cut okay
Skippy I thought that maybe it's been a
long time we checked in with you it's
been a minute and there's been no
progress right you don't have a
girlfriend in fact we've seen a date
that you went on you recorded it we're
gonna we've watched it before we went in
personally I don't I thought it was
entertaining but I don't recommend that
if you're actually trying to start our
meaningful relationship but what I'm
pitching to you is that Skippy we
haven't seen much progress and I think
the Kyle has a good pitch for you for
dating older women if I want it I'll
listen to the pitch I will listen to the
pitcher with an open mind okay that's
all we I just have I have built-in
reservations but I will try and listen
to his advice as openly as I can okay I
will say I'll never try and have sex
with a grandma that the reverse what I
want I get them out you don't know what
you want you just said you be opening
your okay skip you do know what's a GJ a
what Skippy do you know what the ecstasy
that is a GJ @ GJ I wanna grandma takes
her dentures out and gums on your [ __ ]
Skippy don't tell me that doesn't [ __ ]
to give you add Sam H up right now oh my
goodness take that repulses isa that's
that is me what my bellybutton went into
everyone out right okay well Kyle I
wanted to ask you something Kyle have
you ever used a cane as a sex object or
any of these kind of assisting
Walker's dentures do you ever use that
as as a sex toy
yeah I don't know never a wheelchair
before at home they never a walker but I
think it's really cute that dudes just
said on built-in reservation but I think
you you don't really have the the ground
to stand on for options I know I mean
this whole thing this whole thing that
way from there is man look do this 2018
there is no God and you know not trying
something L before you buy it or wear it
rights just you're sitting here you're
setting yourself up for a ridiculous
disappointment and failure wedding how
do you respond to that Skippy I would
way rather set myself up for that than
to ever get a GJ so well to be fair give
no Michael options are diverging or get
a DJ I would diverge in it so fast I
would be totally okay with that
skin if I'm understanding Skippy right
he is calling out your lifestyle calling
in sick I mean I I mean I don't know
that necessarily agree but I mean I'm
wondering how you're gonna respond you
know I was debating whether or not I'm
gonna bring this up that's why I didn't
even email it to your producer we're
talking what--like my actual thoughts on
this see I really I really don't want to
hold you out but I kind of think do to
troll I mean 40 reasons I mean but for
the reasons why stick to the ears Austin
Utley the boss thing is not for the same
reasons I was looking at the on the
YouTube page look at the TV stuff so
whatnot you know dude has this little
moment just like I have my little moment
same thing you know I've caught
grandma's you don't [ __ ] at all that's
cool that's well that's my book and my
little stick whatever yeah yeah but I
was looking I was looking at the YouTube
page and I know I see just trying to get
far enough in a guy's Twitter what not
but then the reason I think these
natural is because none of us monetized
so one times you have look at me look at
me I'm a virgin but I must say I'm not
getting out of this foam kind of life
but kind of confused us to what's going
on here this is a really good act but
you're not getting compensation for so
it probably isn't so I'm not sure what's
fun I guess I'm a little bit confused I
don't understand your theory necessarily
you're saying that you think he's
trolling because he's I get because he's
not making money is though you
said so no no no no what I'm saying I'm
not sure what side of the fence the
falls are like it's so look at me look
at me aversion but you're not being
you're not being monetized so it's kind
of like confusing us of what's going on
here
what's your theory Kyle and I really
good I I see that in the comments
sometimes from people also where they
where people are like he's just playing
a character there's no way that this is
him he's like saying that he's a virgin
and then he's probably you know like
using the microcosm of notoriety that he
gets to be able to one person had to
quote one person to plow tons of chicks
right which is not what it is and I
understand people thinking that but my
counter to that would be like anyone
that knows me like yeah I am good at
three things in this life I'm good at
meeting celebrities up at Sundance I am
good at I was I think that I have one
over the counter to your point there
Kyle it's like a button he has a jar
full of belly button lint we actually
have we have a we have a sample of that
so I I can't think of anything of a more
sincere evidence that a man has never
put his dick inside of a vagina than
that may be possible but I'm calling out
I'm calling out is it a shake is it
something like but you don't you think
he's playing it up that's this is
interesting point Kyle raises Skippy why
is your whole identity
you know defined as Skippy the virgin
why is that your whole identity if
you're not with if you're waiting for
marriage why is it all about me the
version if you won't just like put your
dick in the next hole you see and yeah
and you would mine you would dare to
decline a G job again I find a D job as
repulsive as you find my belly so you
say so
there's so ya know i 100% say God you
describe Kyle can you briefly describe
the ecstasy that is a G job to Skippy
yes well no I couldn't because I was
gonna say it's currently [ __ ] a [ __ ]
but like it can move around that can
squeeze you more because they can more
pressure cuz I am a [ __ ] mandible
they're still the [ __ ] you know labia
minora mature squeezing you what not
right you wouldn't you don't have a
point of reference Skippy how do you
respond to that there's a part of me
that feels like with if this is what my
life has come to where my virginity is
looked at as the same as a guy who wants
to have sex with grandma there's
something really wrong with how I've
been doing things in my life if that
white virginity is compared to like on a
spectrum it's wet at the one end of the
G job and at the other end is virginity
yeah it's not give me it's not even
barely wrong Skippy it's not virginity
it's defining yourself as a virgin like
how do you come then I would say that if
the first TV show like so the very first
show I was on reality show look when I
was 24 MTV month pounds of town asking
what are you doing on Saturday night in
your hometown and I was on a super super
tiny MTV show that was one episode that
ran once back when I was 24 right okay
and then the next reality show I was on
I was like older and a virgin so that
was what so you that wasn't even human
eek about me you were identified as the
virgin during one of your previous
appearances and it's stuck mm-hm
now Skippy yep can I ask you this have
you ever used a fleshlight or any
masturbatory toys to help aid to make it
feel like you're having sex no I didn't
even masturbate for the first time until
I was 26 or 27 describe that experience
to me I'm curious how what was that like
after waiting that long my first I
masturbate yeah and disgust with myself
that I hadn't waited longer like others
that I had known and and even when I was
like okay it's natural this is how you
know like instead of having wet dreams
kind of thing but there's still that
part of me that is like okay the goal is
still to get married so that I'm not
having wet dream
you do that kind of thing did you tell
your bishop did you masturbate it what
was his feedback aha see so I'm forking
out I was 27 the first time I did I know
that I did
can I think cuz I know it's something
where where the underlying principle of
it is that you're you know you know in
the Bible he that looks on a woman to
lust after her
you know is committing a sin in his
heart kind of thing so I get the
reasoning behind it and it's tough to go
I mean like I went like five months
without doing that there's to be huh I
was really proud of myself
let me ask you this Kippy if we bought
you a flashlight would you use it
no not even y-you said you put your
dignity yeah what's the difference
you're willing to but you said you could
put your dick in a tell by but you can't
use a flashlight I'd like to hear your
bishop explain that okay okay okay so I
was joking about that because I thought
that you guys were joking also because
our Jedi never Skippy what I ever put my
dick in a tail product of a car no not
once not ever like if we're being if
you're asking me a serious question the
reason why I would never tell my bishop
about that because I would never do that
kind of thing I would never have sex
with inanimate objects okay I thought
you guys were kidding and I thought you
could tell that I was kidding with that
too Skippy does that make no no I were
on the same page we're just were World
War two okay I know I know you would
never do such a thing but on the on the
flood guide I do think that if we sent
you some kind of masturbatory toys if
you're already masturbating I think
would be interesting feedback I know for
example they have flush lights that look
like buttholes you can even get weird
with one of those would you use that I
mean no no not like why Kyle we need to
get blessed we've got yeah we need to
get flashlights with teeth less gums
that's a great idea as far as I know
that's all exist yeah that's a [ __ ]
great idea okay well I don't I don't
feel that this conversation is going
anywhere Skippy I have to say although I
love you you're not very flexible you're
not willing to help yourself
if you I mean you
I really want you to have sex Skippy I
really want you to have sex yeah um
how's mom and cosmos
I really am so tempted to hang up on the
guy right now because you're talking
about my mom so get the button ready
[ __ ] you dude and if I that's disgusting
and guys at this point I'm legitimately
pissed off at you if you're going to not
tell him over saying that to me okay
that's my mom we're not about some
generic grandma's right dude yeah you
right Kyle is his mom and I do think
that was way about you that's what I
call it it's his mom it is his mother I
think that we should respect those
boundaries Mormons are very family
friendly you know they they have units
what you said that about your mom man
this part sorry mother
is it a problem Skippy if someone finds
your mom attractive like hey Kyle's
attracted to older women like if you had
a really cute sister and I said your
sisters attractive is that a problem for
somebody to say to you I mean it's you
know what I mean like Kyle he is
attracted to older women okay I just
boarded it terribly i warded it terrible
I could have said a million other ways
what I mean yeah I I guess I would say
put yourself in my shoes and what would
you I mean like if it's and I get that
not everyone is the same where people
were not allowed to be tracted yeah
mother are they not allowed to be
attracted to your mother
yeah but just just put just put yourself
in your name what I like you heard
someone talking about I can't I can't no
because you know I know tvp's come out
there's pictures with me and my mama a
nice girl already and I went on Reddit
and I was holding YouTube they were
ridiculous sexual comments about my mom
and you know what haha that's fine
enough I can do it though but I'm not
gonna like it I said go big and you're
right that's me and that's just how I
just look this role off why though what
I said was [ __ ] if I said the wrong
way send it the wrong way
yeah I hope he thinks your mom is hot
let's leave it at that I think it's fine
he has no intention of having sex with
her Skippy
he thinks she's a tractable lady that's
what he's into and we could just leave
it at that
cool leaving it at that I look forward
to our next act yeah me as well any time
Skippy
god bless you appreciate you Kyle keep
doing what you do
Skippy keep not doing what you do which
is having sex Kyle the cougar chap thank
you so much for calling in and helping
to contribute you know I feel like we've
been through a lot we kind of went
through a lot
we started somewhere we entered
somewhere very different that I didn't
expect but it's all been good we've
covered a lot of garlic dicing by the
way thank you for apologizing I
appreciate I appreciate him doing that
that was very mature yeah overall that
was really mature I'm like I'm gonna get
up and take a piss and I'm gonna go bang
this grandma gonna be awful anyways good
place here she actually walked in while
you were talking I'm like I'm busy but
I'm gonna go smash go smash that but be
careful with the Kyle I don't want any
more broken [ __ ] all right okay all
right bye guys thank you all so much ego
bye
boy that was crazy yeah we're gonna roll
to a commercial we right back to talk
about that as well as voice messages
news and of course go to your room Ethan
right Treader see you guys soon oh thank
you too honey
for sponsoring us millions of people are
using honey to save money while shopping
online and why wouldn't they it's free
takes just two clicks to add to your
browser and saves you tons of money it's
ingenious and one of my favorite things
about honey is how much better it makes
shopping on Amazon let me give you an
example you install this cute little
plugin it's cute because it's so easy to
install click boom it's there while you
shop online it searches for coupons to
get you the best deal ela I know you're
a coupon shopper I know you're open
trillions and trillions of different
tabs I used to do I used to be in deep
into the coupon game if I'm being honest
you know they're out there like you're
shopping on Macy's and you're like Macey
coupon codes save 50% you never know
they're out there what it does is it
automatically does it for you at
for example check this out Papa John's
Pizza oh I'm just getting a pie all the
sudden honey's like Oh Oh got him saved
you five bucks mm-hmm
that's like from 20 I'm just saying
that's extra cheese and extra pepperoni
right back onto the pie for you on
Amazon they also work amazing they
search two million sellers on Amazon and
find you the lowest price it even shows
you the item sir price has changed so
you can set if you want to wait or buy
it if you do decide to wait just add it
to honey's droplets and it'll notify you
when the price drops honey's got your
back you'll never overpay for anything
on Amazon ever again there's no reason
not to add honey to your browser today
it's free takes just two clicks to
install and we'll make sure you always
get the lowest price on Amazon add honey
to your browser for free right the flip
now at join honey calm /h tree that's
joint honeycomb /ht it's free it takes
two clicks I guarantee you're gonna save
money with this
I've saved billions billions actually a
couple hundred bucks not villians but
they know there's no reason to
exaggerate you're gonna save money
you're gonna say pizza money guys thank
you too honey grab that app appreciate
y'all
welcome back everybody I have to say I
was kind of surprised by how off the
rail Skippy lasted off because what did
Kyle say he said he's like how old is
your mom and can I smash that Skippy
went like Hulk you saw red I was kind of
surprised by that some people take this
stuff very personally like say anything
you want but don't talk about my mom
that's funny
so hood people yeah Mormons and Israelis
but I like how he takes it as such an
obvious given that like what if you said
it about your mom you know I mean it's
like I'd be relatively fine with well
guys I hope you enjoy that are you team
Skippy are you team Kyle it really ended
up in a verse to this moment there but
they work it out Kyle apologized he's
very polite
you could have doubled down everybody
but you
yeah and escaped at first I thought that
Skippy was kidding when he was a fellow
he was not I guess part of the reason
was that mom was like in the room right
next to me didn't want to like yeah
don't upset mom what did you say that
yeah he was like and especially when
you're talking about someone that's
really close to me right good name yeah
Mormon moms must be scary as hell she
probably still like slaps him with
rulers yeah that makes the whole thing
so much worse why would he have his mom
there for that call its Skippy dude you
saw the video he took his mom on dates
and [ __ ] you know we still have a little
jar with his belly button you can carry
it around with you everywhere I'm just
waiting for the right moment to I think
when we have a child either we can pass
that heirloom to them you cherish this
will say to him or her in our wheel
chair forever didn't we sell that off
for charity
no there was the big one as a little
100k we robbed me of his lint vault I
kind of wonder what see if he's
replenished that now hmm probably
started a new one yeah I wonder what's
he up to
well anyway um thank you to Skippy and
Kyle I think they're both champs and I
love the beautiful minds that they had
TLC heroes yeah TLC Heroes is really I'm
trying to think of a good name we've
seen what catches
TLC heroes is great all right let's go
do voice messages all right boys we
gotta get rid of that guy's woman he's
way too [ __ ] happy that's like the
sound that's the song there's no Bell
hears in his head right mm-hmm comes out
of the Children's Hospital gotta get it
that changed all right what we got here
and what up Ethan and uh Sheila it's
your boy Nick over in the Sacramento
area of California
I'm a parapsychologist so I work with a
lot of poop and with all the [ __ ] you
guys talk about
it's good [ __ ] versus my bad [ __ ] so
it's nice listening to you on my on my
graveyard shift so keep up the good work
I haven't seen any new moves lately so
it'd be a good idea make sure nice and
move under your mouth like yeah have a
great day
thanks for sharing you glad to hear that
there's good [ __ ] out there I haven't
worked on new well I did have a move in
uh you gotta work on those moves
yeah the new ones the right parties
mm-hmm that shit's crazy I'm do I tried
doing that [ __ ] you're gonna be like
it's tough not fat first of all first
and foremost and there's like an age
that goes with the dentist right you
have to be a bright young man kind of or
should be a little red shirt boy if you
want to trip up sorry I'm saying if you
want to transcend the age gap that goes
with the dance you're gonna need to work
harder that's true I don't know if I've
got it in me but I'm like to transcend
my moves dr. rudi johnson here and i
just want to just give you a heads up
like it's time to stay away from the
road and bars and people like that not
because we need to keep people separate
but because they're going to destroy
your career and tweening like that's a
bad idea so don't do that okay thank you
to my podiatrist yeah very safe advice
so now on appreciate that thanks for
stopping in thank you okay Ian from
Toronto Ontario Canada and I just had to
say I can easily replace your other Ian
sorry he's irreplaceable do you see what
he just sat here and dead I'm not I'm
not gonna sit here and listen can you
put that PowerPoint presentation in one
hour
are you freaking kidding me and the
battles of the ants no one will ever
defeat him I hope you're listening in
you know there's this movie with John
chow yun-fat where he has to go and
parallel universes and kill all the
other versions of him so he gets
stronger you know what I'm talking about
and on yeah I'm gonna look
is going on and in this world enos
rushing you okay
all other Ian's I invite you to
challenge are in Ian's like my Pokemon
he's like my star Pokemon I dare anybody
to step to me with a better in my and
they can battle that uh is that
bulletproof monk no no no okay give me a
break let's move on
hey I'm Cameron from Central Missouri
calling in regards to what happened to
Iraq I felt like Amazon like this stuff
like that just in regards to it's not
something that's solely on Amazon
Walmart and Target or starting to
experience the same problems as well
with all the other parties he's talking
about there online because Walmart and
Target and all these other retailers are
starting to have third-party sellers on
their website as well trying to compete
with just so stupid if I go to Walmart I
don't want to buy like you can't he's
talking in regards to the fake Amazon by
the way I was listening to that podcast
and I was really regretting not being
what do you want to add what do we miss
just that I hate this the garbage that
they're selling you know I stopped
buying from them it's immoral honestly I
hadn't I ended up returning like every
everything I bought from them recently
it needs to be addressed like recently
we bought I'm like okay I need a net for
our pool to clean our pool and I sorted
by ratings and price because I know
there's so much [ __ ] so I says okay I'm
gonna buy the most expensive one to
avoid buying garbage so I just find one
that's like 25 bucks which is a lot for
something like that it's got five stars
I can get it okay it's such [ __ ]
garbage it's in three pieces and you you
screw it together for Christ's sake and
it's wobbly and unstable wobbly it's
just falling apart
like seriously I don't know it needs to
be addressed it's a huge problem the
Amazon I bought I bought shelves that I
was gonna put together remember yeah and
I start to put it together and so
whole thing and it's like heavy and
there's a lot of pieces and once I start
putting it together the pieces don't
actually fit over each other right
because like cheap plastic and they
didn't do quality control or whatever
the pieces are supposed to fit and they
don't and it's just like all the
progress I did so far just there's
nothing to do now I had to undo it pack
it back together so I can return it and
then you gotta return this like heavy
package the nightmare it became nobody's
talking about this this is a huge
existential crisis this is the one this
is the one then the one no one was the
one and it's it's gently this the plot
of this movie is [ __ ] off the wall
dude he goes and killing alternate
universe versions of himself but and
they're all trying to kill him because
when you kill alternate version already
it really is you become more powerful so
ian is the one I hope you I want to toss
the gauntlet of there and what was this
guy hey it's a free shipping Walmart
Target approve of this so you should
totally buy from this random company
something on their site some companies
like Best Buy like I worked at Best Buy
and I have a lot of issues with
customers coming in demanding like give
me this price on this font that Amazon
from one but it's sold by those third
parties where it's like you can't trust
them yeah we don't know just like the
customers you guys talked about where
you don't know if it's the real product
or it's a fake product just that had the
prime swap he's saying people come in
for price matches on all this garbage
mm-hmm third party [ __ ] it's a mess it's
a hole man but it used to be on Amazon
that if it was prayin you knew that this
is like a poor boy youth right yeah
that's what I always thought that's what
I always thought too and I didn't have a
problem up until like a year ago yeah
especially recently like the past few
months everything I bought from them was
like broken even [ __ ] as shitty as like
medicine this is fake yeah unbelievable
somebody's got to talk about it and if
that person has to be mints well then I
guess I'll be that hero all three later
I'll be the one
[Applause]
I take it very seriously because I came
here from Israel where you don't have
Amazon and here I was like Amazon this
is like heaven you can it's it's amazing
yeah and now it's all ruined it's ruined
we're back in the dark ages this is now
we got a go shop at Home Depot speaking
of the dark ages we have one here about
bidets what up poops just taught me long
as from Seattle's I wanted to spread the
good word of the bidet you guys had one
don't be afraid the thing will clean
your [ __ ] I do have a very very hairy
[ __ ] so give it a try get one of the
warm water ones spray straight in your
[ __ ]
will be clean of the whistle I have a
bidet and it is has warm water I have
never used it because I don't understand
when you scored it with the water how do
you clean you have shitty water on your
ass I'm suppose I've been advice to use
a wet towel
my bottle white I really wanted to call
in to explain okay so here's what I
propose but is not available right not a
flight yeah your brother he's he is
unbelievable proponent of the bidet
he thinks though even with the wet wipes
you're not as clean as you can get
whatever they're apparently I'm not I
just don't understand the process of
drying your ass with [ __ ] in it like I
take [ __ ] I know that [ __ ] gets caked on
dude what are you still supposed to use
toilet paper in conjunction with the
bidet or once it's wet you can use
toilet paper or toilet paper first
toilet paper first thing if this court
rinse down well what I want to do is
bring your brother in he can't we can't
debate this you can give me instructions
and then the following week I'll use it
and we'll come back and report in
because I feel like the bidet we need to
get yeah you wanted to call in and he's
got he's gotta know it's already
prepared he's really yeah well I need to
prepare it's [ __ ] up cuz your
bathrooms the one with the bidet we have
two bathrooms and I can and now once I
start loving the bidet the captain going
over [ __ ] in running between
bathrooms you think I'll just use yours
I never thought it was mine anyway it's
it's a bathroom that I'm gonna [ __ ] your
bathroom you made yours and mine
ladies bet I'm thinking in training from
ripping bumpers off of trucks I'm
hanging with truck nuts you know down to
my knees you know what I mean thank you
very much for that I thought it was the
hater but it's just a ladies fan all
right let's bring it back I'm right
there with you buddy
come hey yeah Ethan and Ella loves the
show just gonna say it's Jordan from
Melbourne Australia not to be confused
with the Jordan the frequently called in
so I just wanted to let you guys know
just what's the previous podcast though
what your well I work I work for a major
water company out here in Jalan little
little off state of Victoria down
Australia and just we have a massive
campaign going on right now where
basically we just want to educate people
and that people know that flushable
wipes aren't actually flushable even
though they they're advertised that way
so I thought I'd just bring that up with
you guys things I've been working for
this company for a while now and it's
pretty pretty clear to everyone that
work in this industry that they're not
actually flushable it's just I also just
want to say how much I love the show and
thank you for telling me how she loves
the show but you can't you can't have it
both ways you can't be like Oh crush
your dreams over there
this whole thing with baby wipes it's
like all absurd and I talk about baby
wipes and people are like I've seen snow
it's it's just happening now everywhere
were people are waking because they're
advertising it as flushable well if but
okay if if flushable baby wipes are
somehow like a destroying the plumbing
worldwide and they are that's [ __ ] up
that these people are able to say hey
flush yeah that's why it's becoming
illegal you know what I noticed on these
packages of these yeah maybe maybe it's
time to start squirting - straight up
false advertising is what I was that's
kind of what they say on the packaging
is only only one at a time yeah come on
you think I can clean up my [ __ ]
one way get real I'm flushing like eight
at a time do you really
I'd on a grill no more I would say Viet
Mo's I'll go one and all I can serve the
space I'll do like five wipes you know
what I mean mm-hm and then like if I
have to go in for the second one it's
like all right
usually going for the second one if I
was going for a third one it's like this
was a third one third is like ish but I
usually wrap it up to three I think I
can't live without it no I'm addicted to
baby whoops you don't understand if I
take a [ __ ] without baby wipes its it's
you don't understand I can't get my
[ __ ] clean I'll believe with toilet
paper by the time it's clean you don't
understand I think you gotta throw it in
the trash can I don't like to I gotta
tell you I don't like the idea of a
bunch of shitty rags and the you know
I've got bin right next to me but hey
sometimes you got to do do you know what
it because the thing is like you've got
your hand under there and you're wiping
[ __ ] and there's a real beautiful thing
about just letting it go but when you
have to do all this and then you bring
it out and you're confronted with what
you've done for me you're confronted
with what you've done and then you have
to not do a whole new act of this it's
like you know I don't want to see I
don't want to see the murder scandal
okay I relate to that I don't want to be
confronted with my crimes when you when
you're wipe you don't look at it I look
yeah you look at it yeah do you look
every wipe well I don't know but you
gotta track the progress right certainly
at the end you got to know right now
what's the difference let me ask you
when are when are you done wiping when
there's no poop left art will you quit
when there's a little poop left or do
you wipe until it's all clean no usually
there will be no nothing left
how deep do you like I'm sick or
something right if you have diarrhea
then you don't want it good two figures
but how deep do you go in when you're
wiping what do you mean do something
where certain levels of deepness like
you can do a surface level clean but
sometimes you scoop in a little bit no
no sometimes you scoop you
know what I mean no does anyone out
there know what I mean sometimes you
scoop a little bit no no you're doing
well okay sometimes you can rub a little
bit deeper all right I guess so I I just
saw I just missed a call from your mom
Ethan but she then she texts me you you
rinse with the bidet and dry with the
toilet paper is what she's saying
so that must be nice for her my
asshole's Harry if wet weather paper
touches my [ __ ] it disintegrates and
sticks to my hair all right let's move
well we should try it it's actually I
hear Dan my dad says mom my mom wanted
to call in about something I was like
that's too off-topic
my dad goes what about how she lost her
virginity that's a funny story I was
like no your mom just called and she's
got strong opinions on this I don't know
if you alright let's take it put it
through we got a we got a dollar in on
your okay no it's too much okay next
time we'll be ready it sounds like we
need a whole episode the rest of 2018 is
gonna be you'll have to get it's gonna
be like a full court case of like we're
gonna plaintiff and defendant we need to
have representation we have to have
adequately both of your families it
seems like this is everybody agrees but
me basically is just me against the
world as usual well I haven't tried to
be there yeah never I'm gonna try it ice
we should try it before we start it's
kind of a calling that we just moved and
while we have it it is a calling
it's a calling yeah big Ethan in Hilo
this is a twitch dot here to calling in
to get your thoughts on going from [ __ ]
the shower after that hygienic and if
you've ever done Ethan in Gila he's ever
done [ __ ] the shower how do you feel
about it [ __ ] the showers pretty
standard shoot the show you take a [ __ ]
you take a shower I wouldn't do that
unless it was just like running down my
leg because I got [ __ ] to do is he
asking about
like know why opinion between that's a
good question but what I would guess is
yes no wiping
well if you're okay with that I mean
isn't that just I always a shower just a
giant bidet in a way yeah except that
year no it's not it's not
I would not only why I'm opposed to no
wipe into the shower because you
understand that well it depends on the
severity of your [ __ ] how severe was
your [ __ ] as a [ __ ] running down your
leg and you didn't even give it do one
courtesy wipe is there like a psycho
scene where Bloods down the drain with
[ __ ] on the bottom of your shower you
left the question to open yeah expand
more okay what else we got talking about
a piece from Los Angeles and Ethan in
ela I only handle one question for you
when are you gonna release a solo
Antonio song with post Malone that [ __ ]
is straight fire so flow like Antonio
flow like Antonio thank you oh gosh
Austin is so [ __ ] busy these days
he's been on tour yeah pretty much since
the watch yeah he's been yet basically
since the live show you know he's
playing actually we have 30,000 Cedars
now yeah well we're gonna see him soon
hopefully when you from when he finishes
I have a dream that we were hanging out
with him really just remembered were we
making so flow like Antonio no honestly
I think you might be too big of a
started to debase himself to doing like
meme rap but maybe not we're honestly
I'll work on it I'll try to make a pin
but it's very unlikely I'll say that we
need a ghostwriter - yeah we need a what
was in Quincy what was his name in
Quincy Jones or whatever Quentin Quentin
Quinn Miller hi this is Metro podcast
and I'm gonna call them talking about
how you know it's like Skippy and the
Cougar chance you guys are making their
own wack pack and I thought that was
really awesome
he said you didn't want to be whack pack
because it'd be like a beast at Howard
so I couldn't help but think of the gas
pack
gasps back then gasps back um I like
it's it's not bad but I like I think we
need to give credit to their beautiful
minds and I'd like to play in the TLC
gang as well the TLC heroes steal
someone years of TLC but but what if
they yeah that's what that's the thing
like Joey salad yeah maybe we could be
like the learn Edmund Joey is part of
the gasps pack in a way isn't it he
definitely gasps Becker all right
there's one left here Jenna this is Josh
from Iowa I was hoping I catch you
before the podcast just let you know
don't go to the office today
thank you it's a little too late I wish
somebody with 104 in two hours too late
all right well thank you everyone for
calling in if you have messages where
that were where's the freaking number
you got it on the screen or something
for the voicemail box yeah we could
throw that up on screen I dropped it
into our script earlier it is where'd it
go I guess I'm a 1/8 to 1/4 8 5 0 4 if
you want to leave a voicemail
read it again that's eight one eight
take over one four eight five zero four
all right do it 10 more times
please don't we got a couple videos you
want to go on to Ethan go to your room
you want to just get on with it or
should I watch these videos I have to
we're not let's just do what we got
we're deep in now this is the it's been
two hours already
yeah it's been two hours this is the
part this is my favorite part of the
show because there's no pressure and
it's just like anyone who's listening
now yeah is in it for the long haul I
feel that too I wonder if we could ever
feel that from the beginning I know cuz
I feel like the first 30 minutes is
always the most like rigid and tough
yeah but I don't know if it's like going
back to our how we had this show out
like let's review how we how we did this
show we started with Ian coming out wait
that's not we started we started with
the tongue wise Oh thing whatever just
like housekeep ILA's back apple verse
razor it's like what can you really do
it
that I had a troubles I was like is this
interesting you know what I mean like is
this meaty enough but sometimes you got
to open light mm-hmm how do you hit the
ground running with these podcasts I
don't know Ryan Seacrest was great you
know we should do ela maybe start it and
watch our like the top cringe video of
the week like if we open with the Ryan
Seacrest that might be an interesting
way to like lube up you got to lube up
with some top cringe yeah to grease up a
little bit and then be like oh he'll is
bad like that's kind of a good idea
right yeah nice I kind of like that hey
guys welcome to podcast let's jump right
the flip into it by the way heel is back
alright
where was I just take to the whole
podcast go back to the top sure
whoever's watching now Dolph clearly
doesn't care we could talk about
anything at this point
I mean alright let's watch some [ __ ]
how many people are watching right now
Dan 17,000 well
the Loyalists the truth there's nothing
of value left here my my doggies mmm you
know we do have some guests coming and
finally we've been doing log2 well next
week we've got Tom Segura nice that's
exciting
yeah I'm a fan of Tom he's a funny funny
guy that's and then in in and uh then
the nice it on my calendar ever and then
the week after that we have actually
know Tom is the week after that oh oh
yeah and that's why I don't see it in a
book up next week okay should say that
you guys were gonna be on Monday with my
Tiger belly right yeah Bobby Lee's it's
your boy Bobby Lee I'm excited love
those guys check them out there all
right let's get on with it
jerk off video go ahead Dan Julie jerk
off forgive me her calls
great awesome okay but like imagine we
started the show with that everybody's
like that was a [ __ ] terrific I'm
hooked
instead of like Oh apple verse razor
everybody really [ __ ] cares about
this people people care people wanted to
know what update with ela cuz she was
gone last week you know see I don't know
if it's more the psychological thing
before I not loose we're not Lewis I
don't think it matters what we talk
about her but maybe not know there's
there's probably something to that look
we talked about your update but we
didn't really get into the nitty-gritty
because there's a lot to talk about with
your family but we're like oh that's too
much at the beginning yeah you know
we're overthinking it people don't watch
podcasts to get hooked
do they who cares or do they I don't
know who knows how do we make this show
that I've never watched a podcast so I
have no idea right hmm me either clearly
that's why it's run like this I just
watched it for the first time the last
episode yeah on my flight back I want I
listen to it for the first time that
weird for you to like it was very weird
yeah she says I just felt like I wanted
to do respond to anything about stuff it
was weird to not be able to and we
should we should had you call in or
something didn't we do know I was up I
was literally on a airplane
oh no when it was live it's too late
there it's like right no the night I was
I don't it's a podcast so it's like
almost boring by nature but I personally
want it to be more more active I wanted
to I don't know I'm trying to i want to
elevate it but i don't know if I'm
making a mistake maybe just let it be
mm-hmm I mean there's we trying too hard
I don't know there's some people here's
a comment in the chat just now this is a
long-form podcast I think it's good that
it naturally builds you set a tone that
way mm-hmm-hmm my fear is that the first
like 50 minutes are the most boring and
that sucks because that's when you want
people to keep watching but maybe that's
normal with podcast is it
I don't know cuz I don't know that that
maybe I don't know I find like when I
listen to Bill burrs and and Rogen's and
while Howard who not podcast necessarily
but I I'm always usually pretty hooked
in on the first 15 minutes mm-hmm you
know by the way anyone who complains
about our ads listen to Joe Rogan that
guy reads ads for [ __ ] days I'm not
complaining I like listening to him read
ads because it's like interesting for me
saying how other people do it it's it's
crazy though he gets in there for like
15 minutes you just see people saying in
the chat they don't need to be to get
hooked my god these are the guys that
lasted two hours into this lame-ass
conversation that's most of everyone
almost I mean we at most we had 20,000
and now we're at 17,000 yeah it's the
vast majority you're sticking around
right but still like I'm talking about
growth somebody turns it on who's never
listened to before and we're like a
razor is a well yeah but it's it's gonna
be hard no matter what a razor is really
crushing it don't you think I'm figuring
I'm trying to figure it out I'm reading
the chat to get some feedback and this
guy says I disagree I enjoyed every bit
the very beginning of the podcast mmm
okay thank you are you reading the ones
that are like well I but again there's a
lot of nonsense comments but everyone
already closed it who was bored and I
mean you're not looking at the and the
bright side not hear you I never do I
mean I'm not a bright side well anyway
my pension is to try to elevate this
show we got it I think for my sake I
think I want to find a way to further
the beginning to snap like imagine this
play this again Dan play this again
you open the video hey welcome a street
podcast Julie jerk-off amazing welcome
everybody to the extra three back Adam
who's not who's closing that that's
right there
whose wasn't it no commentary we could
just edit this one to just start right
here we can't we're on YouTube we can't
edit it take it down re-upload probably
get double the views these guys saying
we're here because we love watching you
guys thank you I love you
Iran and macaroni for an hour for all we
care
that's what I want to hear I don't want
to hear criticism I don't want criticism
I want to hear people who say you could
literally just eat a bowl of cereal and
scratch your ass will not watch I like
the bar being a slowly I don't know it
scratch your eye sure well maybe that's
interesting to someone I don't know but
I like to hear that thank you appreciate
that a lot
how did you get the jerk off from
kerkhof well she's obviously got
something else on her mind Julie and
everyone in the crowds like ooh Kirk oh
um this person who's saying I think most
of the growth comes from offense
my laptop's about sucks yeah all right
that's the thing with the razor actually
hear that I don't know it's just it's
not doing it okay sorry you know what
basically he was saying that it it's the
growth comes from like friends telling
friends I guess you know I know I
appreciate I listen I don't get me wrong
I love all you guys I love all you
mother at flippin efforts you guys are
the greatest
you can't want to do the best show you
can dad I read I just by the way Oh
should we address the shipping on Teddy
fresh because someone was just asking
about it I don't know if that's the
right medium you can at this point we
could talk about anything I'll give you
[ __ ] nobody's listening what you want to
talk about it but just we had a lot of
issues with the International shipping
being carry fresh highly vaunted fresh
and the reason is that we were trying a
certain plugin that allows you to pay
the customs ahead of time and so the
shipping was including that
mm-hmm but we realized it wasn't the
best so we now we cancelled it so now
it's back to normal shipping front yeah
the shipping on international was insane
but we fixed it it's still expensive but
that's out of our control well that's
what it cost the Bennett International
shipping sucks because you don't
understand that all these countries have
doll these different tariffs and duties
themself so what the plug-in did is
their pre charge you for duties so that
so that it doesn't get held up if you're
in Canada for example or the UK and you
order something from Teddy fresh there's
a there's a chance that they're gonna
hold it at the post office and make you
come and pay a duty this this
circumvented that which is helpful for
some but honestly just and ended up and
a lot of people paying more money for no
reason so whatever we leave it up to
chance but if you were discouraged by
the shipping price then maybe check
again maybe it's better because we
didn't make some changes oh we should
maybe we should open with that what's
the news what's the milk about shipping
uh hello everybody and welcome we've got
an update about shipping for us yes did
you know that FedEx has given us a
discount recently just make me fall
asleep anyway I think those 15 minutes
are crucial and I want to find out
because we're upping our production
quality as you guys can tell our least
we're trying I don't know if we are but
we're trying to be more organized you
know have everything more put together
it's a lot of extra work we've been here
on these days now in the podcasts we're
here since like you know yesterday we're
working all day we get here at 10:00
a.m.
these guys are here earlier been working
all last night I mean we're here for
hours and hours and hours like five how
many memories back days in Alex dancera
four for backstage and me and HeLa
grinding and I'm wondering is it worth
to like all this work we're putting in
like God oh we work into our let I don't
know 15 first 50 minutes are crucial I'm
wondering I want to find a way to move
on play the [ __ ] whatever we got next
damn people stealing stuff
by that bolt stealing stuff I jerk off I
would have crushed our views would be a
40,000 right now okay excuse me
all right here we go go ahead is that
yours
little love oh you need some help yeah
this is our stuff yes this is your yeah
it is this is all ours
all of it the chairs the back of our
stuff my kids yep that's my kids I'm
sorry yeah shocking they just can't
believe it [ __ ] sake okay I'll let it
slide I'm glad I made it in time no no
step away from my [ __ ] how about I like
how it ends with the camera being
slapped and then it just ends there's
some hoods blood like is that really the
heist is that a heist moment to steal
somebody's like Beach canopy apparently
sell it for 50 bucks awesome like what
what is the State of Mind where somebody
has this epic beach set up with a canopy
and towels and boogie boards and you're
like I'm gonna disassemble all of it and
walk like that's not an easy operation
that's not grabbing a wall at us like
somebody's shoe mm-hmm was it an honest
mistake
no way well what kind of theft is that
what kind of mistake is this your walk
into someone else's like that
wrap my head around trying to
disassemble and steal a beach canopy is
it kind of a thing though that like any
bags just start stealing like that it's
kind of a you're quiet oh my bad I
turned it down for for that video yeah
isn't it a thing that you know like
older people I haven't heard of such a
thing is that a thing yeah all those
people steal they steal a lot all right
I'm looking for the elderly I guess they
weren't necessarily what's the theory
they need they need some money they
don't get a lot of elderly people have
money problems and everything and they
also just kind of happen
they don't give a [ __ ] are you here
about a race let me let me pull some
statistics I'm pretty sure this is this
is a magic dancing that about a race of
people and they just don't really
inspire this is an age thing so come at
me come at me elderly I'll take you all
as old people still [ __ ]
who knew you know people say when I'm
old I'm just gonna take heroine and
enjoy myself is that a real thing the or
I think like that's not because like
yeah I don't think that that that would
really be enjoyable I used to think that
I would be like you know what when I
retire I'm just gonna play World of
Warcraft it's gonna be beautiful you
don't enjoy the same stuff that you
enjoy when you were a kid yeah when when
I was in college I was playing or like
high school I was playing EverQuest
world Warcraft like you know for 12
hours a day and that was my bliss I have
never enjoyed anything as much like you
know when I retired that's all I'm gonna
want to do right now I'm afraid of that
when I retire yeah what is it that like
when you're 20 and the prime years of
your life you can spend 15 hours playing
World of Warcraft but when you're 60 and
you have nothing to do you feel like
you're wasting your life is that twisted
why don't you tell us when you're 60
okay
report I will check in then thank you
I'll be checking in for sure it's an
update on that it's it's not necessarily
that that like most shoplifters are
elderly or anything like that but many
people who have never committed crimes
in their life
start to do it when they're older and
the study that I'm seeing I guess it has
more to do with mental illness and
Alzheimer's and things like that
my it the rate kicks up 60 plus so that
is a bit of an ageist thing I mean
you're blaming old people for stealing
but it's actually just mental illness
that's kind of twisted its able us do I
know I'm on it it's I got a pee really
bad okay let's move it on we have we
have two more segments here we got Ethan
go to your room and we've got ela does
the news so let's let's bump it to Ethan
go to your room okay let me eat some
crow here let's pump go to your room
[Music]
all right welcome everybody to the new
and create a segment here on the HP
podcast where I face the music I say a
lot of dumb [ __ ] here on the podcast
over hours and hours of open mic time
and a lot of this stuff you know you
come out here you say stuff ends up not
being right okay fine
there's a couple of things I want to
address the record on okay first of all
this one I frankly feel bad about this
was egregious this was very bad so I'm
gonna clear there no I need to make a
correction on this one do you have the
clip up Dan can you play the the
original one about the London acid
attacks my statement yesterday I let me
grab that real quick by the way someone
suggested to start with the news maybe
[Music]
interesting suggestion by the with no we
don't have that clip we have we have to
cook for the other one right for
Christ's sake for the next one that's
the one that you had Ian me why I wanted
both I don't think I have the other one
mm-hmm alright well what I said what we
were talking about I read an article
that acid attacks were all on the rise
in London well it was related to that
dumb prank you remember right there was
a young Arab man who was a youtuber who
got banned off YouTube or pretending to
throw acid in people's faces and I just
well what I was saying is that acid
attacks were on the rise in London
apparently it's a very common thing and
so he was kind of piggybacking off that
which was really [ __ ] up and I assumed
because he was a young Arab man that it
was scaring people more because there I
thought the acid attacks were acts of
racism Mormon terror sorry terrorism I
was dead wrong on that and this truth of
matter here I'll read this statistics
released by the London metropolis police
in the BBC provide a breakdown of every
recorded acid attack over 15 year period
by age gender ethnicity borough hate
crime and outcome it's the false picture
of the findings so here we go the
suspects were 74 percent of the time the
suspect was male 7
four percent of the time and the victim
was male 67 percent of the time just six
percent of the suspects were Asian I
guess the the assumption was that they
were because you have these honor
attacks and then at the Arab world or
the Southeast Asian world were or is
it's like in Pakistan or somewhere it's
like a Muslim thing I'm probably making
a idiot
correct what I asked them what did the
ayah
it happens in India too which is you
know primarily Hindu so it's it's it's
cross-cultural let's say unfortunately
the point is I can't come to Ethan's go
to your room Ethan and then make I can't
do corrections on my correction I'm
counting on you guys to help me out here
what what it says six percent Asian what
country are we talking about India
Pakistan the continent so I think all
all of it all of in Middle East Middle
East is in Asia the Middle East is Asia
okay alright so I'm okay the point being
that it's not Muslims primarily doing
yeah I'm London right that's the point
so that's the point the point is that
it's actually what's happening here is
that there's gangs in London biker gang
as I read who who are doing they're
throwing acid in each others face some
kind of retribution and it's not
terrorism or it's not you know Arabs or
Pakistanis or anything like that so I
made a absolutely wrong conclusion on
that one so that was just my bad okay
it does say well something though that I
would assume that you know well yeah to
be fair you lived with me in Israel for
five years and it is in Israel that is
the reality usually when I'm saying
there's some sort of an attack like that
is it is usually terror right related
and and that kind of stuff so I can see
why you made that assumption but that
was a bad one I felt bad about that one
I want to correct the record the other
one this one's a weird one big catching
a lot of flak I've noticed for
apparently sending out Nazi propaganda
that's interesting accusation to level
against me
specifically had spoken about the
bombing and raised him oh here here's
the clip I can't hear it yeah let me
resize it this is a super big for some
reason here we go started over oh my god
come on
dead air after the Nazis surrendered low
quiet the Allies went and bomb Drazen
was like a historic City German Germany
said to be one of the most beautiful
cities that ever exists and it was
untouched by the war because it was just
a civilian city there was no military
there two days after the war ended the
Allies England specifically and I think
America they firebomb the whole [ __ ]
City just out of straight revenge and
they killed 300,000 civilians something
like that so anyway basically I had said
that now the real story is that we are
talking here about the book yeah one of
my favorite books of all time
this slaughterhouse-five written by Kurt
Vonnegut where he details in his novel
being stuck in a meat locker and raised
in as the fire bombs are falling and he
comes out afterwards and the moles on
fire everyone's dead and then and the
Germans there are making him and other
American prisoners of war literally
shovel the corpses of the families and
the children and all these people that
were just absolutely destroyed during
that bomb okay so I'm Paul anyway the
truth is that apparently the German
government issued some propaganda that
estimated the figures of dead to be
around 200,000 I guess to better equate
war crimes of the Nazis against the
Allies death tolls have been estimated
as high as 500,000 but a 2010 study
commissioned by the city estimates that
it was only 25,000 now the thing is
people saying like I'm saying Nazi
propaganda but in Kurt Vonnegut's book
he says on June 35,000 you know I spent
a month in Germany
and I'm pretty sure when I was touring
Hamburg you know in Hamburg in northern
Germany there's cathedrals that were
bombed during the war that they left
intact as a reminder our tour guide
there and the Germans were saying that
the Allies were blowing up civilians
cities and we left these cathedrals to
remind us of what happened and I'm
pretty sure that the tour guide there at
the head also told me about Dresden and
it was this horrible crime against
humanity but it's in the book that I'm
talking about so it's kind of rich of
them to be able to accuse me of like
[ __ ] talking about Nazi propaganda
for Christ's sake and this is just from
2010 I'm just quoting Vonnegut but to
correct the record it was 25,000 not one
hundred thirty-five thousand or three
hundred thousand or whatever I said so
clearly the Nazis are on the rise and
they're really using me for for
reference here so I'm not a Nazi yeah
and Kurt Vonnegut is my favorite author
and that's where that came from so
that's it was that interesting nice feel
like you just want to clear the air on
those does that you know what the it is
good to say but spit that that one
doesn't bother me that much I don't I
don't I'm I was wrong on it I don't
think anybody's taking that information
being like the Allies were just as bad
as the Nazis that was my point
no I'm curious I genuinely am curious
what about the whole aspect of it being
after the war was over
damn I'm clear about but I I was reading
on Wikipedia the other night they were
saying the Americans who called the
bombing were saying it was just the
fight in retrospect because I guess what
the way that I heard it told and
Vonnegut was that it was just this it
was a just a straight-up revenge attack
right I'd always heard that you know it
was criticized because it wasn't really
it wasn't really a military target and
yes and it wasn't but I just looked it
up really quick and the war in Europe
ended in May of 1945 and this bombing
happened in February so it was a few
months before the war was technically
over so I mean it was still work I guess
it begs the question of well at any rate
it doesn't begged
I mean 25,000 people still died I think
it's an interesting lesson by the way
but the whole thing that I found
interesting about it I was not to equate
Nazi crimes against allied crimes first
of all you know we've all seen a Vietnam
that were perfectly capable of
committing horrible atrocities and World
War two with Japanese internment camps
but I find I found the whole comparison
interesting in that like when you fight
the monster you have to be careful not
to become the monster yourself 25
thousand civilians got charred is that
much better I don't think so
you know I mean I I don't know it's it's
still yeah let's not talk people died in
the end you know it's justified sure but
like you know [ __ ] sake there's like
a video of me talking about it like this
huge expose about like h2 h3 talking
about Nazi propaganda I was like dude
give me a [ __ ] break as a Jewish guy
they're saying that you're not see that
I don't think anyone actually thinks I'm
a Nazi but that like I'm a mouthpiece
for propaganda anyway I was wrong okay
whatever that does for you but the the
acid attacks was definitely a mistake
that I honestly should have corrected
sooner that was just [ __ ] flat-out
wrong and with that being said we just
have the news left all right
instead of news my scene that's right
yeah just the names Guardiola do we have
a new so roll the bumper oh we have a
bumper all right let's do it
[Music]
[Applause]
all right I can't see it but it sounded
like a hoot ela you're all set up to go
all right
first story Trump implements tariffs on
Canada Mexico and you well honestly that
one I have to say I don't know much
about it so well I'm sure it's
complicated but I also know that you
know Canada and Mexico are like our
close trade allies so yeah my feeling is
it's not a good thing cuz they're gonna
retaliate and it's just gonna turn into
a bunch of isolationism which generally
isn't a good thing but I don't know
yeah believe Canada has already
announced that they're they're hitting
us back dollar dollar basically
generally when the world and the
countries start shrinking into
themselves it's not a good thing
mm-hmm but again I don't know I guess
they think it's I don't know it's
supposed to help with there's a trade
deficit know what's next yeah a lot of
enthusiasm for that stuff Netflix
briefly Netflix tops Disney as the
biggest media company in the world
that's crazy
that is pretty nuts Netflix um surpassed
Disney in market value Thursday hitting
a high market value of 156 billion one
hundred and fifty six billion that's
their value the the dollar value of
their company it's their market cap so
it's it's their value on the stock
market essentially mmm one hundred and
twenty five million subscribers that's
half of the whole country of America
they they their where's that oh yeah
they are now accounted for thirty-six
percent of all down stream Internet
traffic
and YouTube is second and 15% Wow twice
as much as YouTube yeah over twice I got
much time on Netflix but we have it I
think but they're talking about usage
yeah clearly people are using it yeah I
find it harder and harder to use Netflix
if I'm being honest you know what I mean
i-i've enjoy you put Netflix I don't
have a beef I just have a hard time fine
I have like choice paralysis I got going
on there and I'm like I don't know what
to watch III find myself spending more
time on Hulu personally it keeps
changing it's like one month you'll do
all of sound on Hulu yeah I enjoy both
though I always feel like there's
nothing to watch on all of them just
straight up you're a tough cookie um
friends did you hear about the
spider-man I have her story what's the
story then do we have the video yeah let
me cue that up so there was a child
hanging from a balcony and well that's
it
[Music]
[Applause]
watch this clip I wonder why didn't that
guy yank him up cuz he had a hand on him
third guy in the balcony yeah yeah yeah
it's I mean I've seen that debate a lot
it's it's it's kind of hard to Dan
you're quiet I'm sorry I turned it down
for the video um yeah it's kind of I
think there's like a barrier there so
he's like afraid you know I'm surprised
the kind of strength the whole yeah
that's what I was thinking too [ __ ]
well either way that guy is unbelievable
here oh man
yeah so now is action now he's called
the spider-man of this century and um
they're gonna give him citizenship
because that's Odell would that happen
America do you think somehow I don't
think that would happen do we even have
the ability to be like hey you're a
citizen good job
what's the legality of that either way I
love it god bless the French um the next
story is about the televangelist who we
talked about before he he had the whole
story about him wanting a private jet
yeah and now he wants to upgrade the
private jet or what wouldn't a new one
and he basically said that he wants his
followers to pay for it right of course
it cost fifty four million dollars fair
and his reasoning was that if Jesus was
here would he want to travel in like a
shitty airplane with no room for the
legs seriously yeah that's serious yeah
it is and he said he said it'd be on an
airplane preaching the gospel all over
the world
what is he just walking down
on the earth below huh you know I mean
apparently it says here it's his fourth
plane yeah
what a [ __ ] dick you know yeah Oh
what didn't Jesus want a fly first class
it's like bra do you understand anything
about Jesus for planes so he did
clarifies 54 million you could yeah so
many people with that how much II
airplanes cost that's a lot of money
well it's like the craziest private jet
you can buy it's not just like a starter
kit no yeah and you did say that he's
not keeping all four of them he's good
he passes them so now he only has one
currently in his possession but he wants
to pass this one and get the new one
like an iPhone you wants the new iPhone
it that's now that's that's a that's a
man of God he's sharing the wealth he's
passing down who is he passing down the
jet still how do you get even with that
where was it he said somewhere I think
it was other ministries oh god plus god
bless Rhett what's his name Jesse Duplin
dupes in his name for Christ's sake
Dhupia Duplin reverend Duplin can i
please
oh there's also video he made in
response today to the backlash the guy
if you can call it you got the vid thank
god us friends i guess you've noticed
all right why doesn't he go you know the
whole thing is being said about me
concerning this plane first thing I want
to say this they never started the story
his idea is T Thurs was I wanted to be
completely honest and friends like you
who's supportive this religious person I
started it they did not how he's God by
being honest so you'd know that I've
owned three planes I don't have four
planes right now I don't have a 50
different planes
okay I've had it for 12 years this wild
that's a long way away because we
believe in God for the 7x to come in now
what's so amazing about this we had a
partner right man I think it's really
wonderful and I'd like to read what he
said he said I'm a long time following
for it
your ministry I'm disturbed by the huge
volume of negative press you are getting
reporting you're trying to dupe
followers and do complain I'm sure
there's a lot more to the story I'm not
looking for a lengthy explanation but
can you help me figure out what to say
to people who say you are doing wrong
that is a great thank you for say that
first thing first I've never raised
money for the plane I put it in our
magazine and said believe not with me
it's a vast difference between believing
me and asking for money I takes money to
run anything that's common sorry but
believing God was some people don't
believe that when I say the Lord said it
so I'm gonna say because I believe it he
said you don't need to raise money for
this this will just come now I've raised
money for a lot of other things and
there's nothing wrong with that because
religious organizations do that but this
one he said this one will just come
little did I realize that people would
pick this story up and you know when you
start picking up a story people start
adding things to it taking things away
things of that nature and it gets all
mixed up because it again this is coming
this is the truth here because I'm the
one that's turned here by first I've
always believed in you and you've always
believed in me many of you know that I
preached a 106 million households in the
United States of America our total
outreach of our ministry is fine people
get a load of this this is the spitting
image of like a fake-ass religious
person
everything's gilded he's got white shiny
ass teeth here trying to defend his
decision to buy 50 million dollar
playing with congregation money a
preacher Duplin can I please can I get a
lot for that jet bye can I get an amen
for my jet you know Jesus wouldn't walk
the earth with a donkey yeah he said
that he says Jesus you think Jesus would
write a donkey no he'd be first-class
yeah that's basically what he said
that's not the Jesus that I think I know
but you're more touched he said actually
many people hold Jesus to be a simple
humble guy but truthfully he [ __ ] he
drinks and you know he rides first-class
so that's why I do it
Jesus
Jesus had the new pair of Yeezys let me
tell you and he was all decked out in
off-white and Gucci so imma be needin
that 50 million I might need that 50
million to preach that good word but
cannot get a Amen No
next up Bob G is suing for tonight for
coffee right sore loser if you ask me
mmm we've talked about it before but I
guess now it's happening so what are the
details what exactly are what they're
saying is that for tonight didn't have
the battle royale mode only until like
they saw that pop G was that a violation
I honestly don't see how it could
because it's not probably doing an event
but it's that broad of a lawsuit like I
mean I mean that's just like you can't
it's like trying to copyright reaction
videos yeah what happened with the rack
brothers it's so pathetic guys stop like
I don't think anyone would look at this
and be like you know what stop dude it's
you invented a genre cool sadly invented
well no okay
so the mod Brendan green was on our show
yeah he invented the battle royale
format as far as I understand in his
previous game hmm he invented it in a
mod of a previous game then he made a
full game pub G surround about that mod
and then blue hole bought it and they
made pub G together but there were other
battle royale games no I'm not a hundred
percent sure he may have entered he may
have invented the genre but I mean what
you--what like half my like that's like
saying you know Wolfenstein or doom
Sonic is a ripoff of mario like whoo
yeah like what you know Mario owns
platfor gamers I don't want the first
three two shooter I think goes
Wolfenstein I don't know but it's like
saying Oh doom ripped us off yeah it's
the same company your point stands right
sure okay
I I specifically don't like this because
it stands in the way of innovation it's
like yeah yeah let the world move on you
know what I mean your competition should
be run by who makes the best game
pudgy's player ship has been dropping
off like steadily because listen the
game it's it's it's been static you guys
don't make it better you guys don't my
ears bleed when I play it I've literally
get hearing damage when I play it it's
not fun was he involved in the h1z1 yes
that was his [ __ ] right that was as long
as the model that one was a donor
regional so he and so he invented it but
when I yeah the problem is when you try
to not allow anyone else to just curious
like is there some more specific well
anyway whatever what I understand that
is it that is what the lawsuit is about
i I don't like it I really don't like it
mmm by the way the game is different
enough I play both you know the
mechanics of 49 is completely different
than the mechanics of pubsey there are
two very different games mm-hmm yeah the
whole building thing in fortnight is
like completely absent from pub G yeah
the way that you played that two games
are entirely different it's just I don't
know it's wack what else we got next up
is in Ukraine there was a fake death and
that they staged basically a Russian
journalist was somehow they figured out
that they put like a hit on him Russians
put a hit on this Ukrainian journalist I
think he's actually Russian brain fake
the murder
okay so it's a Russian exile living in
Ukraine that they were trying to kill
right thanks
okay and so they wanted him dead and I
guess he knew it and then they decided
that the best way to solve this whole
situation was to fake his death that's
great and then catch the
basically they put any hit on him so
they faked his death and then they asked
the person who was gonna kill him to say
that he did it and once he said that
they would they would pay him right
because there was like a hit on him even
though he didn't do it he would pretend
to to say that he was the guy who killed
him and once he was gonna get the money
they had proof that there was someone
that was willing to pay for his death
doesn't make sense not really
then do you want to explain it well from
what I understand it's that you know
they knew of this guy that had
supposedly was offering money to kill
this guy and so one of the people he had
offered money to betrayed him he that
that was the guy that like alerted this
journalist to it and everything and so
he played along in this whole ruse he he
said yeah oh I killed the guy and they
announced it in the news and the dude
was they hired the guy who was paying
who paid this fake assassin right they
they hauled him in this plot and so how
about that yeah and then the guy came to
pay up he's like hey thanks for often
this guy here's here's a hundred grand
or however much it was they came and
arrested him got him sting sting
operation that's crazy that's some James
Bond [ __ ] yeah
well Danny shows up in like there's a
video right ah let me see that you've
got a video of him showing up from the
dead the no that's crazy
no sound is there sound there's no sound
on this one cuz it's one of those stupid
people ideas like I got the original
that guy's got the most Russian looking
face I've ever seen in my life if I can
say that a little bit yeah no I got
vetoed on that you know all right this
isn't it very interesting without any
sound cool that's pretty wild
that was hard to explain but interesting
Snoop Dogg set a Guinness record for
Jane and juice plus they made the
biggest gin and juice drink Snoop Dogg
made the biggest gin and juice drink oh
we have got a video
oh that is a big one
[Applause]
Snoop Dogg is giving us just another
reason to love him the 46 year old rap
legend helped cry yeah that's a big-ass
chin in g1 they got a whole audience for
this [ __ ] I can do that I can get a
big-ass glass and put a bunch of gin
juice in it called together like 2030
pointed out his the straw has a
watermelon garnish like an entire
watermelon that's dope
oh they crossed the line even mmm god
bless - peace out you Snoop Dog's the
best he's out there you know what I mean
he's active he's breaking World Records
I can't think of a better thing to do
with my time to make the biggest Jin
[ __ ] ever and get a whole crowd together
for it
you know mmm I can't think of anything
better to do really by the way Warren G
was also there of course he was German
Zoo escaped lions tigers and jaguars
caped a zoo and a bear and then they
captured them apparently it was part of
like there was a flawed and that was the
reason it happened but it just sounds so
funny like two lions two tigers and a
jagger escaped the zoo not ostriches not
not monkeys predators alpha predators
whoops and did anyone get hurt did
anything happen
the bear did right yeah was it
what kind of bear was it I'm not sure it
just says that a bear also escaped but
um they shot him that for some reason
here's some footage of the flood this is
this is why it happened right here oh
[ __ ] first your city floods and now you
got Tigers on the prowl for your ass and
they're probably hungry too
whoops okay Sue's be crazy
am i right Sue's keep a track of your
animals am i right people right pound it
keep those last story was no effects the
band oh yeah had said some crazy [ __ ]
about the Vegas shooting so and what he
got into trouble what I wanted to say
was you know what I'm not even gonna say
it I'm not even gonna go there I just I
when I saw this I record I was like
there's been a lot of people talking
about certain things to be an offensive
I saw this and I was like now that's
offensive
um well word the stuff they said for
example good they were they did a show
in Vegas and they just kept going on and
on about the in regards to the Vegas
shooting they're like at least those
fans were country fans are not in Vegas
good yeah I'm not saying that to a Vegas
audience man about that Vegas shooting
at least they weren't at least they were
country fans and not punk rock fans and
what he said it to be exact was I guess
you only get shot in Vegas if you are in
a country band or they also said we
played a song about Muslims and we
didn't get shot hurry play those are the
quotes of it I know there's clips at
least they were country friends and no
Punk is there no clips I'm trying to
find the cell phone footage it's pretty
bad but alright
and then there was a bunch of they lost
some really big sponsor that was gonna
do a festival with him and they they
apologized on their social media
Facebook Twitter and oh they're thinking
of like an even better apology I saw a
video that was like really brutal
ah all right whatever we don't have it
yeah so that's it that's all we got um
what do we do we have anyone coming next
week on the show no not yet but we've
got some great big ass guests coming I
will let you know when we figure out who
those great big ass gets are we know uh
well you said that tom is coming
Thompson you are next and then I think
it's the week after that we've got
I know it's two weeks after that uh
Chris D'Elia it's coming in very excited
for that yeah that should be fun and
then Bobo is coming in yeah we got bo
burnham I believe the week after that
you really yeah there's July 6th item
and July 6th we got Bo Burnham and on
Monday evening we were gonna be I don't
know if this does Bobbie livestream his
podcast that's a good question well
either way we're never caught it live
yeah well night yeah I'm not sure either
way we're gonna be doing that on Monday
we just posted a new video on h3 if you
guys haven't seen it a lot of fun there
there's some new t-shirts on Teddy fresh
can check him out and that's about it
guys thanks for bearing with us this was
a steady decline it got it was started
bad it got good and then it just steady
decline maybe that's the way to do it
either way thank you for watching we
will be here next week
shredder is literally pulling up the
carpet yeah shredders like let me the
hell out of here guys have a great
weekend love you thanks for sticking
around
wish you the best Tata appreciate you
all the great things in the world the
best to you love happiness and so much
more
everything you ever desired a beautiful
tailpipe to put your dick in a butthole
fleshlight
a hot mom whatever it is in your heart's
desire this weekend I hope you attain it
with that being said I am gonna enjoy
this weekend I know I will either you
can enjoy this weekend yup Dan oh yeah
and oh yeah he's back on the conic forum
so he's gone making a new PowerPoint
guys we'll see you next week thank you
for watching top of less
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]